[Music]
shout out to the island man
this your boy
uh what's tom hanks uh what's tom hanks
this is chat
chatting at the island
[Music]
it's 4 20 man
time to spark up brother
[Applause]
we pray to the green my
my i don't know
not good
okay but today sponsored by honey
hey
[Applause]
okay the game
oh
and in the role
what's the big old doinks that's young
king dave you don't know about young
king dave the goat dude let's go go
all
right
dave young king dave what's the no
what's with the doings oh you
can't have no we we've talked about on
the show have we not out here smoking
doinks with the amish big old doing in
amish he's in a town called amish and
he's smoking big old doinks
would you like to see yeah yeah yeah i
want to know what we're talking about
here but
big dory today is of course april 20th
4 20.
blaze you know i don't even smoke weed
but smoke weed every day
it's a fun day to celebrate
i have no idea who this guy is what
y'all talking about dude he's the goat
man smoking big old doinks and amish
out here an amish smoking big joints in
amish
he's in a cornfield
all right
big old doings
that is a big doink he tragically passed
away a few years ago
wait what happened he had uh i believe
it was a lung infection oh my gosh
and uh wait a lung infection could that
be from the big doinks it it could be
the betrayed him but his size didn't
really help and um
he was a real one so rip young king dave
rip one for dave
today
on this day
this is dave's day well if you're into
it rip some big old doinks at home
because we got a fun game here today
the last time we played this game we
played who's high but we needed to up
the ante this time
so what we have here which we're going
to play oh can you cut to it i'll pull
i'll move it in
so basically we're going to be playing
who is high
drunk
or cross-faded or sober
or
or you know fasting for ramadan which is
uh
which is our good friends who we love so
well
responsible kings and queens
well you're already guessing that
category
hey oh i don't come on
you gotta wait up ethan
jump in the gun a little bit here jump
in the gun you guys are sober
not necessarily true
it is
thank you for your concern oh my god
you're tearing
the whole set down
well anyway
of these
remaining
non-ramadan observers
so
one so some of y'all gonna be crossfaded
some high some drunk some so but is
there only four contestants or
uh five okay so there's going to be five
of you guys and you've already gotten
one wrong so yep what no i'm kidding i
was like
um
you know last year by the way dan was
he blazed but he's like a regular blazer
so he says dad you got to get blitzed
today you got to get donked out i don't
know if i'm even smoking though right
that's true yeah doing huge bong grips
but whatever whatever i imbibe i will
you've got to get to sufficient uh the
we're gonna do it after the break
right
so we're gonna do it after the break
because we still have to run a show here
so because i don't need my whole crew
being totally bl blinked out
but it's gonna be fun it's gonna be a
great one
for a change
changes uh at the top of the show here
we have lots of goofs i'm gonna hold the
goofs off until you guys are doing
dink doing think joint we're getting
dink doing today baby so let's just do
our stories at the top of the show here
uh top of the show
we've got
where'd you start oh this was this this
story is kind of dub
so mr beast
is being accused
of creating an unsafe
condition for his videos
and this was first showed up in a philly
was this a philly d
well it was he did report on it but it
was making the rounds uh on all the
typical uh websites
so like what was funny is that we tried
to track down the store origin of the
story
uh he did this video where he put a guy
in like solitary i watched this video
i watched all of his videos actually
every day
so he put this guy in solitary
confinement gave him ten thousand
dollars a day
uh put two up to a million dollars
and then every day
he removed one of the items from the
room
and they're saying oh this is just cruel
that you put this guy in a room it's
like uh
unsafe but here's the thing like a at 11
seconds at the very beginning he
literally has a giant red button by the
egg it says exit push this button you
can leave any time
guys
do you know what the
if you think this is prison i don't know
what the hell to tell you bro
personal chef he had a hot tub hot tub
an ice cream machine no but the most
important aspect of course is because a
lot all that stuff went away he ended up
being there for like 30 days or
something or 20 days
but
what
is important is that there's a giant
[ __ ] red button by the exit eco push
anytime and leave any time
now
correct me if i'm wrong because i've
never been to prison but i don't think
they have those there
maybe in sweden but not here
they're like listen if it's too much for
you i get it you can push the red button
so it's a non-story like totally a
non-story
um but then there's it's this story
floating around
by the way you the worst i want to see
philly d talk about it yeah it became
enough of a story that uh
that the guy in the video felt compelled
to tell people no i was totally fine i
was safe there was people checking on me
and everything but um
i i don't think anyone was really even
mad it was like one of these weird
things where
it's it's like a phantom outrage like
nobody's actually outraged but
everybody's
adamantly defending the person who's
being uh canceled did he put him in oh
yeah he did not only did philly d
sees phil he's a smart boy he needed a
thumbnail title that's what happened
right not only did he
talk about it which i'm doing now
but he put it in the thumbnail and title
of the two guys
the truth about mr beast's accusations
and backlash
so does he acknowledge that like it's
not even a real thing
well he says that criticism is [ __ ]
but he doesn't really mention that
there
so what's really interesting
is that
we tried to track down the origins of
this
and it's like the snake eating the tail
kind of thing yeah it's like one media
reports it and then another media
reports it it's hard to pinpoint exactly
where it came from
but philly d
shows a tweet parties and work parties
possibly the best thing to come from the
pandemic and the switch to work from
home is just as philly lost some weight
eh skinny legend wait
wait
he lost a lot of weight
uh perhaps yeah
dude what philly go get it boy damn son
get after it what
he's looking good
it's really training for a fight who's
he going to fight no i don't know i'm
going to fight i'm going to go dump you
it's going to fight scared scum for me
yo philly okay apparently i'm the only
fat one left on youtube now it's just me
and nick acado oh no
347 is where the tweet's at so we just
i'm sorry to do this to you phil but we
did a little investigative journalism
ourselves because you know we hit hard
and we never miss on this show never
never have we met
um what what was it ab 347 347
okay so
here it is
he said his team were endangering josh's
mental health with him noting
so
is this the tweet oh yeah yeah that is
the one yeah so solitary confinement is
considered form of torture in many
places i don't like the direction these
videos are going
right he cut out the likes dislikes we
tracked down this tweet and it had zero
likes
yeah right so missed the mark with that
one how how did this turn into a story
well from a tweet with zero likes yeah
that's [ __ ] fascinating yeah and
you know philly may have just got it
from the other reports uh that we're
going around i mean like i said there's
did you see that same time
reports
uh i think i did to see it in at least
one yeah that's awesome yeah he might
have just pulled it from there
my suspicion is that the person who
wrote the original article used their
own tweet because who the [ __ ] else oh
careful conspiracy but i'm sorry again i
cut you off no no i didn't make a point
yeah no no no just that it is
interesting how sometimes
again i mean it was enough that the the
people directly involved felt compelled
to like make a statement and push back
on
i don't know on nothing nobody was
really that mad the guy made over 300
000
yes
completely voluntarily you know wasn't
forced into anything you know what he
said that uh they were checking on it
you
know
yeah yeah they were checking on them all
the time you know why solitary
confinement is torture
because
i know this is crazy you can't leave
oh right yeah no that is that's one of
the worst parts of it for sure so that
that's kind of the whole
point i was just don't communicate with
anyone i mean he was being talked to
every day every day they would come in
give him more money someone would come
in and like play with him and hang out
with him for a couple hours jake paul
facetimed him on one of the days yeah i
don't know why that happened that was
part of the torture
i was just watching something about
super max prison and you know that that
[ __ ] is pretty gnarly
that'll [ __ ] mr b should make a video
about that now oh yeah well you do get
paid as a prisoner what like 20 like 13
cents a day or something
if you work if you work yeah but this
this super max prison you you are
allowed out of your jail cell one hour
every day yeah well that's more than he
got so yeah
right just saying
that and a new fiancee because he
actually popped the question once he's
done but despite the crazy amount of
money what seems to be that he got
engaged
mr beast and his team were endangering
josh's mental health with him noting
generally solitary confinement is a form
of torture however i do have to say in
this instance i think it's a really
stupid [ __ ] art is it so what do you
think about like reporting on something
that isn't a story just to defend him
because you're still bringing attention
to a story that doesn't really exist
yeah i mean sometimes
you just get got cop
you got got by stuff like that i don't
think it's necessarily malicious but
and i mean
it probably became
news where they are report worthy to
fill again when when the people involved
felt compelled to like respond
oh so that that was before he reported
on it
yeah oh interesting it was a great
opportunity for me everyone needs to
relax
why are people mad for josh when josh
isn't mad which makes sense because josh
is an adult i just can't get over how
skinny he is
who made a choice at the beginning and
every consecutive day and or moment to
continue being there resulting in him
getting 340 000
all right well yeah i mean listen
i'm listening oh here i am
philly
how many thumbnails am i up to on this
guy's channel now oh we should do
another count yeah we need to we did
that that was a few years ago let's see
here's one
i see dolbrick being
dangled quite a bit
yeah i believe delbrick might be making
a movie there's only one person
ahead of you when we did it but the the
count but that was like 2019. wait
delbrick is making dude dolbrick is in
like every thumbnail this is a threat to
my supremacy
i think you started that trend so
you think i can take that as a point to
me yeah
damn i see myself another dobrik dobrik
dobrik holy [ __ ] a few hassan still lots
of hassan oh no the betrayal
it's coming from within the house
um
god only one of me this is tough
you're falling off oh here i am here i
fell off oh man
here i am
another hassan though
it seemed critical a lot too
wasn't pewdiepie at the top before
yeah it might have been pewdiepie that
so it was close definitely have
fallen off a lot since then i do see him
still somehow i don't know how
like look at this one from four months
ago what pewdiepie mukbang controversy
exposes like what what the [ __ ] a
pewdiepie mukbang controversy this guy
[ __ ] this guy pulls stories out of
thin air bro and god bless you though
skinny legend but like holy [ __ ] what is
the pewdiepie mukbang controversy
i don't uh i don't know well here let's
collect the video what's up
bastards welcome back to the final
scheduled philippines the first uh star
15 the year 2021
it's titled pewdiepie shares concerns
over mukbang videos right
so you must still like criticize them or
something
but the title is
the title was like the what pewdiepie
mukbang controversy exposes this is why
he's the best in the game dude we can
learn a thing or two from philly oh here
i am
oh yo
it's it's me and capcav
hell yeah
here's mr b yeah so there you have it
you know there's this leaderboard we
need to
oh even all gas no brakes made uh
made experience with a hassan
yohassen is racking up points
all right
i'm getting worried here i am again
shame on you ethan klein and hassan
biker
i remember that was a circus yeah yeah
zero
zero ground to stand on when it comes to
clickbait at this point though we have
fully embraced the meme bait yeah on
this channel we did a poll about we had
one where you were in the hospital yeah
yeah no i agree for sure well we have
one more year in the hospital where you
really were well then we had one where
you were definitely there was one in the
hot where i was in the hospital and
barely attached to anything that
happened in the show
my favorite was the one with you with a
mug shot with a black guy but to be to
be a little bit fair to us this is a
comedy show and he's like doing the news
yeah but i mean this is part it's part
of the youtube game i don't think i mean
you know not all clickbait is created
equal obviously for instance click
baiting your daughter having cancer
perhaps you know that is a good way to
get views
listen billy is a skinny king and we
love him without uh reservation
that's it i just thought it was
interesting how that story yeah respond
from a tweet with zero likes but like
you said it's likely
it's likely that he was just
well like you said the other guy make
commented on it so
right
at that point it is a story well there
was a tick tock going around as well but
the tick tock didn't provide any
examples of the backlash as well
interesting
um
okay
great the same just saying
logan paul is doing a new nft project
after his last one dink doink was a huge
hit
super excited for everybody to make lots
of money on logan paul's new nft project
oh yeah
on my face take a drink on my chest yeah
yeah
you're my favorite car what stinks can
you pull up the ding dong craft
[Music]
[Music]
it's
incredible hey guys today i'll be uh
taking your money for nothing
invest it looks like ding donk is valued
at one quadrillion 24 quadrillionths of
a
penny
oh it's on the rise uh no it's not
that is not looking good my friends
wow that is a pull that is a
that my friends
is
basically worthless going to the moon
baby
that is like critical mass of worthless
right there
that's funny because if you go to like
one day or 24 hours
you go
hey that's looking pretty good a lot of
movement
and if you go to max
that's very bad
[Music]
so there you have it
well don't forget about ding dong
because there's a new one
you know he's got this concept i'm just
gonna talk this camera
i'm not gonna watch this video because
it's two minutes the concept's not bad
he takes it he goes i'm gonna take the
cruise video i can every day
uh polaroid not a video or a polaroid
yeah you're like okay
fine i thought he was gonna make like a
book or something which is like a cool
little memorabilia thing yeah i mean
if i was going into this blind this
trailer is so well produced and
genuinely makes it seem kind of cool
except but
the ending was like oh baby yeah
there's the part where he just randomly
slips in and also doesn't have tv uh and
that you know is a little eyebrow
raising yeah did um
did mayweather punch him in the face too
hard because one of his eyes is like
hell lower than the other
i never noticed that
one of his eyes melted down
am i crazy
it might just be the shadow
lighting
not so broken though
i see what you mean though but
oh um i'm a strawberry
anyway so let's watch it i guess because
whatever so awkward
hi my name is logan
my whole life i wanted to be the biggest
entertainer in the world
and that somehow led to me fighting
floyd mayweather
and then a couple months went by what
was supposed to be this peak monumental
life moment just felt like a moment
i still it wasn't enough i wanted to
create something that was timeless
something that reflected who i was
behind the camera and then
i came up with an idea
99 originals it'll be 99 photos that i
take every day over the course of 99
days an artistic journey actual art i
can't stop thinking it's the only thing
i care about picture is an nft
that's that was like gary vee literally
coming out of his mouth
every picture is an nft right everything
i do i'm gonna turn into nft this
morning i took a [ __ ] what am i gonna
flush that down the toilet and wasted
some potential i'd take a picture of
that should they sell as an nft that's
gary v [ __ ]
april 20th
somebody buy it i took my entire life i
need to take the craziest coolest photo
i can every single day for the next 99
days
[Music]
this is crazy it's gonna be perfect put
his blood on the polar one do you have
any drugs
[Music]
oh is that oliver
traitor
i can't believe all he very he
can't believe they verified that
some of these are immature anything with
like tits and sexual it is low-hanging
fruit right
i mean maybe he's right bro maybe i just
have to like
dive a little deeper into my mind
bro
i gotta go to mexico bro the tits and
drugs are cutting it
maverick clothing for germany
across the world
zach that sounds so [ __ ] funny
i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god fantastic or this one look how
ridiculous this is people kill people
pictures like these bro
so okay
it's a coming of age story oh no not
greg paul
one speaking through the window of a van
of craig paul hooking up with the 16
year old
yeah he's like yo that was the craziest
photo i could take of the day and that's
what i meant by like if you don't if you
don't know anything about the context
and watch this like it's a very well
produced it's a good trailer and yeah
and it's got it's got some emotion
behind it and stuff but then like you
see greg paul i don't know if you caught
there's for some reason they decided to
include the footage of him assaulting
that kid for calling him a poster oh
[ __ ] right i was just like in there
randomly it was like i saw when i
watched a trailer but wait that was good
embrace that
dr logan paul was like black out drunk
and attacked some person somebody
insulted they called him a [ __ ] or
something and he was like what'd you say
it is
where was that that was before
this
craziest coolest photo i can every
single day for the next 99 days
yeah yeah so this was like this kid just
came up to him and said some [ __ ] and he
was plot pass out johnny like slapped
him
and he clued that that's awesome
that's
kind of
weird bro
literally he slapped him in the face
and it's in this trailer it's a weird
flex
yeah it's a weird flex you're a weirdo
bro
photos to get one good one we gotten
goosebumps looking at some of your
forwards
the sparkle in your eye about this oh no
i knew this [ __ ] was involved
there he is i [ __ ] knew it
to get one good one we've gotten
goosebumps looking at some of your
forwards
the sparkle in your eye about this he
loves this one
something about authenticity
trying to capture the most amazing
moments on polaroid camera that this is
real
life isn't short you just got to do more
[Music]
i pushed my mind and body to the deepest
darkest depths but in there was [ __ ]
light and it was beautiful
okay i guess they don't really drive at
home but yeah the whole point of this is
to sell each photo as an nft
correct
correct
as like an auction um now what's
interesting you saw at the end there
said releasing april 18th that was
monday
uh what happened he
uh tweeted an update on monday saying
they were pushing it back to tomorrow
which would have been tuesday
and i'm looking through this twitter
right now i it doesn't seem
to have materialized so i'm not sure
what's going on maybe they're having
some technical difficulties or something
yeah because i assume he would have that
crypto [ __ ] announced it here i mean he
was
giving updates on his twitter so
i'm wondering if okay here i'm wondering
if
on the website
yeah there's no information they missed
the deadline
yeah so i'm not sure what's going on i
was hoping to bid on the one of gp uh
in the trailer
but
okay we'll see when it comes out i have
to keep an eye out so i'm kind of
lost for words right now
there's that there's uh
and somebody said if it wasn't actually
if it was actually somebody cool and it
wasn't an ft it would be a cool project
yeah if there was no nft involved i'd be
like this this is this is you know this
is cool yeah
this is like an artistic journey but the
fact that he's trying to turn into an nf
t thing he makes it all about the money
and just this stupid [ __ ] concept
here's proof that nfts are
never going to happen you guys heard
about this story jack dorsey sold his
first tweet as nft for like five million
bucks yeah i think it was three three
million
it went on auction a couple weeks ago
the guy who who bought it was trying to
resell it and flip it
it sold for 250 bucks
did he actually release it or did he
just like not accept the bank i have no
idea i just i saw the headlines yeah he
sold for 250.
oh you got the update here let's see
real quick well if you got an update
before i change the topic uh you go
ahead with that but yeah jack dorsey i'm
just telling you guys this is so dumb do
not spend your money on this [ __ ]
also in 10 years nobody's going to
[ __ ] care about
10 years in 30 days nobody's gonna care
about
logan paul
polaroid nft
let's see
i mean they could if he continues to you
know no
if he becomes president it will still be
worthless
if he's the first man on mars it will
still be worthless
it's just the first line in the article
um he was struggling to attract bidders
on thursday with the highest offer just
shy of 10 000 a year after it was bought
for 2.9 million
he was having trouble getting ten
thousand dollars for it when it was
bought a year prior for 2.9 million
i think you just got to take the l bro
when you're trying to sell it that guy's
in trouble in financial ruin if he's
desperate to get 10k for it yeah
that that's called bad roi
right
okay um so someone
oh sorry go ahead
some of these crypto bros might see this
story now and like just buy it to prove
a point
to prove that the right it's like no the
market is good
i'm pretty sure that this might be what
he's hoping for yeah pretty sure they
missed their opportunity oh i see what
you're saying but yeah no i mean mk for
it i think it would have already
happened
yeah so dan what are you trying to say
something this is totally unrelated but
when i pulled up logan's twitter i saw
this on the sidebar and had to check it
out apparently uh
newsmax yeah good [ __ ] up a graphic
and they were talking about black
conservatives
including bench bureau as one of their
examples yeah he's black
ben shapiro's black as it gets
is that just that
here or what was it
yeah i mean it had to have been a
mistake but it's pretty good yeah
no ben shapiro's black i don't see the
problem with that ass p word
also they must have really been
struggling because herman cain passed
away from covid
so one isn't black and the other isn't
alive anymore one of them's not black
and one of them's dead
that's true huh
that's funny yeah
oops
that's pretty good anyone else guys
i don't see colors so i don't know if
ben shapiro's black or not i just
is he not black
oh i see what you're saying yeah i can't
i can't see color yeah it's very scary
it's very progressive yeah i'm race
blind
are you blocked in
no i'm not you're not okay because i
can't see against you right
you know
yeah
thank you
uh so and then you've got this other
story
ah who gives a [ __ ] let's just have fun
okay
well we are uh at 30 minutes all right
let me just thank our one sponsor honey
and then when we come back we're gonna
get to the main segment and then we've
got all kinds of fun stuff to
the goof and gaff about cool so let's
thank
honey
[Applause]
today's episode is sponsored by honey
the easy way to save when shopping on
your iphone or
computer
i love using honey the really cool thing
about honey now is that they've added it
to iphones previously it was just for
desktops so if you have safari
on your iphone
you can activate it
boom check out all these savings
me and ela specifically ela
shops online all the time and this is
money that we magically save look this
is all stuff ela sent dan
you know 200 bucks 12 bucks
uh 21 bucks it's incredible it's
unbelievable it's happening every week
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for a prompt for
promo codes and applies the best when it
finds to your cart imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
and when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is apply
click coupon apply coupon
dude thank you crowder wait a few
seconds as honey searches for coupons
you can find for that site and if hani
finds a coupon you will watch the price
magically drop you know they have it on
all kinds of sites clothing tech
food
makeup
it's all there
i mean there was a whole plethora of uh
different websites there
and you know
it's so easy to use it's two clicks you
just go to the app store in your browser
or phone iphone and it's right there i
mean it's it's really the it's really
you are losing money but why aren't you
using it you're literally losing money
yeah
i need to uh so yeah if you're not using
honey you're straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show i love
honey i use honey get honey for free at
jointhoney.com h3
that's joinhoney.com
h3 thank you thank you to honey we love
you
[Music]
love you
all right now for the fun part
so what we're going to do is basically
abe and lena are not uh going to be
partaking obviously is the holy month is
it the month is that the month
yeah it's the holy month of ramadan
is it interesting how all goes down in
april
well actually ramadan changes every year
earlier these by like a few weeks each
year so but the lunar calendar right is
it based on
like around that time usually spring i
just go with it you don't even know i
think it really does shift around quite
a bit yeah it does it shifts a few
months or like a month earlier each year
i believe oh so can it can do the whole
year it could be in september yeah yeah
it sucks because when i was younger i
was like fasting during uh winter time
which means i could break my fast at
like six o'clock seven o'clock but then
my teenage years it was like late at
night because it was summer i see
well
there you have it
doesn't pass over move quite a bit too
or is passover it's usually always in
around the same time as
as uh what do you call it easter eggs
right okay this was the first time in
many years that all of all three lined
up as easter passover and yeah okay
this is a special very holy she's just
be like oh
he rise from the dead apparently this
month
i don't believe it
wasn't the last supper a passover seder
am i wrong about that i think it was
actually yes oh it was
i i think so
yeah
oh i thought they were just celebrating
that his ass was about to get toasted no
i think it did i think it made the last
supper was a part of passover
and matzah you know they had hit the
offi komen all that fun stuff all right
well get out there and go get blasted so
everyone's gonna go step outside
as i explained there's gonna be five
contestants
right
cross faded it means both high and drunk
high obviously 420 blaze
chop the brock bro drop the brag bro
drunk or sober and i'm gonna have to
guess for each category
disappointed of course that abs not
participating because last year it was a
it was a
a good one
[Laughter]
dumb [ __ ]
i think you're gonna are you gonna call
us over there to grill us again yeah so
we'll zoom out the camera at that point
all right so you guys go go into the
alleyway and go do your deed okay so
what the people the people who are
drinking are just gonna have to like
chug
i guess so all right
drink responsibility people take
responsibility yes of course there were
this is under a strict supervision of
these nuts no i'm just kidding
all right guys have fun
all right the crew is stepping out
everybody is going outside to have a
good old time on this 420.
i myself am staying sober and sad
i am not high i am just sober
i am high only on life and lexapro
just me and you baby
where are you oh you're at the switching
station i am
yeah so
it's just me and abe oh and lena hi lina
um
so
how you guys doing
we are good i'm hearing an echo through
ian's headphones i don't know how he uh
how he does this oh
test echo test
all right
so uh
how you feeling about the fight by the
way about hundar
i i'm feeling good for the most part um
he seems to be taking it so seriously
yeah i mean i keep being told that me
and him are taking it the most uh
well i would say the most serious but
like we're taking it very seriously both
of us i'm taking very serious because
he's a lot bigger than me um but yeah i
don't know we'll see how it goes as ian
said idubbbz said it's all about the
mystery so you know we found out
apparently
abe's coach
is um
there was hundar went on some boxing
show
with ian with idubbbz and they told them
who abey's coach was maybe you could
pull up that clip
and they're like what that dude's
coaching a b you're gonna get [ __ ]
owned and then the other thing they said
is that apparently abey's coach killed a
man in the ring
yes um
i didn't know that he always mentioned
to me that you can die in the ring it's
no joke but
uh you didn't think he was speaking from
yeah i didn't think you think yeah
exactly so apparent so yeah i mean
but that's not your goal right
i'm sorry that's not your goal going
into the ring no no no but if
do you have a if he dies he dies kind of
attitude or
uh no i really hope uh neither of us die
he's a nice guy
um i hope we just put on a good show
but you can't really die unless you're
like
is it like you have to hit like a truck
to kill someone in the ring or can it
really just happen on kind of a fluke it
could happen i mean you could just get
the right punch in the right area and
that's it
but it's super rare like i mean how
often something like that happen you
know i would
i would assume that it's rare but after
following more like boxing content on
instagram i've been seeing
that it's more common than you'd expect
like even my gym has posted in the past
six months like three boxers
lying in the ring yeah from the gym or
just in general no in the uh
in the actual ring like an actual match
i just pulled up a stat it says which
has more which is more dangerous mma or
boxing considering the number of deaths
in ring based on statistics there's
nearly
one death recorded per year
related to mma but boxing there's 11
deaths per year
yo boxing is way more dangerous than mma
what the hell that's that's surprising
yeah that's really surprising yeah
what
lina how are you feeling about all this
nervous but i'm trying not to stress it
until the day of
well you gotta are you wearing a helmet
abby
no no helmet nope
okay
hoping you'd say yes
uh me too
each year 13 boxes on average die but
come on who how how many how many deaths
are there in about an amateur fight like
come on right
yeah i mean you never know you never
know i've like there was this one guy in
my gym is his first time sparring
knocked out the other guy pretty bad
he was okay he didn't die but it's just
it's scary seeing some of these people
who've never boxed before seeing how
good they are the first time in the ring
so
so someone got in the ring who had never
fought before and knocked another dude
out yeah whoa
knocked him out cold
what is the most dangerous sport let's
see
okay football
hang on let's let me tell you
boxing is not even on here i don't know
why
that's interesting
i'm trying to send this video right now
but love maybe you can help me love is
still here yeah
why are they excluding boxing from
sports
they got number one at
oh boxing is number two only behind
mountaineering
though apparently people just be
dropping dead mountaineering
which kind of makes sense
but boxing is number two
uh
wow
okay well i the thing is i did take out
a life insurance policy on you
i didn't tell you and uh lena i'm
actually the beneficiary
so
just edging my bets there
you know they have you heard this that
um
insurance companies do that they take
out life insurances on people and they
collect the money
that's insane
yeah there was i haven't heard that i
saw a whole documentary about that but
they won't even tell the family and then
when they [ __ ] die they just get paid
out and don't tell anyone it's crazy
that is crazy
the chance says
you guys are talking about death and
from a bunch of people who are stoned as
hell well they're not here yet
they're not here yet i think they're
talking about chat itself i think oh the
chat is blaze let's go chat
listen amy could die a little
insensitive ethan is trying to freak out
ab hey bro
it is what it is
i'm just thinking out loud here i'm
[ __ ] 420 blaze too nothing if you
guys think that's yeah that's funny you
guys should hear what my coach tells me
every day you're gonna [ __ ] die idiot
yeah like
you say [ __ ] like that
pretty much
i can't die yo did you not find that
clip love i want to show
i'm waiting for abby to send it to me
oh
what
waiting for ab to send it to you
do you know he's waiting i sent the clip
in our whatsapp group i'm not sure
how to pull it up because not sending a
discord is too bad yeah now i can throw
this sounded through send it through all
right
so here's what i'm thinking i'm
strategizing already okay last year dan
was high
so i don't think he's gonna do that
also i think zach
doesn't like
oh zach does smoke occasionally he said
right maybe yeah he does
cameron is a cameron blazes
definitely
sam does not blaze nor does ian
no
so who who's gonna be crossfit like who
would be comfortable
getting blitzed
um crossfaded
this is gonna be hard
i did pretty well last year
the only ones i got wrong was dan who
was like obviously probably didn't even
feel anything because he's a he's a
machine
i'm i'm surprised dan got past you last
year
he was he he was acting totally sober
yeah but he's like yeah he smokes a lot
though i i feel like he's uh he doesn't
handle himself
and then kim
i think cam also got me
okay i'm going to be sharp i'm going to
be slick this year
they're taking their time they must be
[ __ ] getting lit
to be honest i i believe some of them
may have started
a little early
i think they don't get too messed up
i think they usually start early
every day
in preparation for this episode
all year round
yeah so apparently by the way amaranth
friend of the show revealed that she
makes 1.5 million
per month easy she said quote
uh
maine only fans alone not including her
other stuff
clears one five to one
for a month pretty easily
god damn that's some cheddar eh yeah but
she's got to be like one of the top 10
earners yeah she is i forget what
percentile it is but she's in the top
she got to be top zero one
but that's pretty incredible
it's amazing how much money these women
are making when they are
owning their whole chain of production
yeah instead of like bang bros make
becoming like trillionaires off other
women's
work
holy god
hey
oh and you know what in the spirit of
420 i've got a great story for you guys
um i don't know if i've told this story
before
uh let me you know what let me wait i
hear them coming let's let them say
exact sounds let's let the drugs let the
drugs settle in their systems
i'll tell my story
and then we'll get to the game
here they come i hear him you're
sniffling like you're giggling coughing
yeah
here comes the
the goofs the goof crew
you guys ready
all right they need one were you there
the whole time ian no
why were you talking
no you just sent me that message are you
afraid of me wait what
about telling the the bonk story
oh i i sent it from that was huge
confused
all right i'm gonna so yeah i've got
i've got this story that was one of the
most traumatic things of my childhood to
be honest
um
but i'm going to wait for everyone to
sit down i see cam
i think ah i think zach is
zach what the [ __ ]
are you even trying to pretend not to be
drunk right now
sac immediately came in
gave abe a great big bear hug
dude he was breathing my ear like darth
vader he's clearly under the influence
he's chewing gum too which i think which
leads me to believe he's trying to mask
just for the smell we're all chewing gum
just for the record everybody's chewing
gum yep dan
dan does not have gum in it
there's other people with gum i swear to
god
all right we'll see about that
so cam came in with this hood down cam
why don't you join us over here if you
can't if there's space
or you got you got the mic it's fine
no we got a camera over here oh you do
yes indeed oh [ __ ] dude that's sick so
uh dan
ian zach sam and cam have all come back
excuse me so as i'm gonna tell this
story as the drugs kind of settle
we were talking about abe's coach though
what is this big-ass file you sent me
love
i don't know dude it's impossible to
send it on this what the hell i had to
download it and from google drive it
does i mean on this quick notice we'll
dance
this is the clip we were talking about
where they talked about abey's uh coach
our killer damn did he change his name
for you
yeah the starkiller sounds pretty
intimidating huh it does uh you know i
don't know uh
i've just been trying to mind my own
business focus on my own training i know
he's got a really good coach out of uh
la too um you know i've got two coaches
any names
uh
his coach is uh wale omotosa
[Music]
wait his name's lucky boy he has a
nickname yeah oh
because he's lucky to be alive
wait why because he's lucky to be alive
because i know but like was there
specific specifically he's just had a
really rough life in nigeria and like
there's one kid in the gym who's a lot
younger but kind of has the biggest
mouth in the whole gym and he was making
fun of my coach saying oh that's corny
and uh my coach is like it's not corny
if it's true and i was like that's a
good point yeah you know he's probably
yeah
that guy sounds interesting he's coming
on the show right yeah he said he's down
oh i can't wait your coach sounds like
such an interesting guy i can't wait to
talk to him
so anyway here he goes
yo that's some respect on the lucky boy
though mm-hmm
this guy's [ __ ]
somebody
he turns to hunter and goes this guy's
[ __ ]
uh lucky boy i'm a toaster he kills
somebody in the ring but
right hand
yeah he's like from nigeria or ghana one
of the two yeah
used to train with freddie roach's trip
and his manager was stephen fetter yeah
[ __ ] bro
damn bro
one of my coaches so i'm training with
mike wait who's your codes then i've got
two coaches i'm training with michael
quick flores he's a three-time golden
glove champ he went to nationals couple
time and then i'm also training with uh
myro burgos he runs headway boxing out
of eagle rock
and crickets who were they
died nobody heard of those ain't no
lucky boy
dude abby's got this in the back i'm in
la there oh you're in l.a yeah yeah yeah
i never heard of eagle rock yeah i know
you never heard of that boy
uh no
so how did that make you feel a little
making
it i mean i kind of felt bad for honda
during this interview he's a really nice
guy yeah it feels kind of bad but i mean
these guys but you could tell that
they're pretty hardcore though but you
know what for once honda if you're
watching this you see what i go through
on the daily
you know
it was nice for me to not be on the
receiving end for once i can't wait to
talk to your coach
abs got this in the bag man how did you
even end up with like the gnarliest
coach in the country how did that happen
so whenever i was offered uh to take
part in this i initially like i
immediately started doing research and
me and lina that like the week i was
offered me and lena went to like five or
six gyms every gym we went to was like
really clean really nice i didn't know
about the reputation of my gym at the
time and we'd walk in there'd be like
some like young guys oh yeah dude for
sure we got you man we're gonna get you
there whatever you need and like
and then i went to this gym and it was
like beaten to hell there's like tape
all over the floor it looks like kind of
you know it looks beating up uh and the
lady at front i was telling her that i'm
gonna be in those youtube boxing matches
and she goes oh she goes don't don't let
anyone around here know that
she's like you just say you're an
amateur and you're learning you know
keep that on the deal oh [ __ ] and then
um
like she was asking about like she goes
are you okay with like someone who's a
little harder on you because you don't
have a lot of time i'm like yeah i'm
used to it i come from a strict family
i'm used to uh i'm from detroit yeah i'm
from detroit i could handle it and then
she introduced me to wally and yeah went
from there so you chose the most [ __ ]
up strict crazy gym yeah
wow good for you man and you looked it
up after you visited and realized that
it had a right yeah i had no idea who
freddie roach was and like i sent the
gym to some of my friends and they're
like holy [ __ ] like that's freddie
roach's gym i'm like who i'm like i just
knew him as the nice guy at the front
door why are they so impressed because
anyone can go there right and train
anyone could go there but like freddie
roach like uh
a lot of celebs go in there and like
freddie roach will take the pros
downstairs like he has a downstairs gym
that's only for pros oh interesting but
he's like tr him himself he was a great
fighter he's a legend himself but he's
trained a lot of like uh
people who won championships like uh
what's saying manny pacquiao oh his son
his son's in there with me every day
manny pacquiao's son you spar with him
hell no
hell no this kid has been boxing he's
crazy good yeah
um but he's really nice guy but yeah no
he's like
yeah scary very scary wow
and um wow well good job baby that's
actually real interesting that you chose
the most [ __ ] up one what do you mean
the gym is all haggard like it's just
like nobody cleans like what's going on
no it's just it's been around for a long
time it looks well yeah like they used
to like have cars come outside and just
open the windows and people will be
there on friday nights just cheering
from the parking lot
just like crazy events and like yeah
like the rings where i spar like there's
like
duct tape covering up the holes all over
it so it's just warned the [ __ ] down
downstairs is real nice but again that's
only for the pros okay yeah but like
there's like no waste or anything like
when i first came in there i'm like
where are the weights they're like your
body's the weight there's no machines no
workout machines just bags and yeah
wow so you're on the prison floor gym
basically and downstairs is the big boy
well that's
props to you brother
you're i think you actually got a good
shot it seems like you've undergone some
real training
from a real boxer
and whoever's uh hundar's coach whoever
that is golden gloves
get this i was real confident because of
my gym then i found out that honda's
coach trained at my gym
so it's like we both know miyagi doe
we're both yeah
do you know who his coach was yeah um
he well my coach knows him uh they're
friendly um oh [ __ ] your coach knows his
coach yeah what does he say about him
does he talk [ __ ]
he's not that type of guy
i mean i don't he didn't say anything he
just said that he knows him he's a
friend that's it see ian's idubbbz coach
was ready to talk [ __ ] about anyone i'd
like to have him
i was like what do you think about this
guy he's like i [ __ ] him up
all right let's get to these uh these uh
inebriated hooligans here
oh i wanted to tell a story maybe i'll
do it after the game
my most horrific 420 story
but i'll save it is everyone feeling
sufficiently as if the drugs are in your
system
you feeling good if they're
there are drugs in our system i mean
people who drank the alcohol you're
under the influence it's it's flowing
zach is the alcohol hit
i don't know what you're talking okay
nice try all right so let's see i'm
gonna enter you guys know the rules i'm
gonna interview y'all one by one you're
gonna come sit with me and i'm gonna
guess
if you're drunk high or both or sober
so let's start with zach who came in and
gave ab a big old
bear hug
[Applause]
i have a seat zach let's see what's
zach has done a 180 he's going back to
his seat
he's make sure the mics
which mics
oh
good man
here is the thing i'm going to put it on
the board
all right zach is this you
maybe
zack shirts king out pretty hard
gotta rep the nash you know cheech and
chong 420 so tell me you got you went
outside with the guys yeah and what did
you guys do out there we just had a good
old talk good old chat so tell me
whoever drank alcohol what did they
drink
uh i was on the level of everclear
and uh some real hard grain alcohol a
little moonshine what was it that they
drank daniels jack daniels shots how
many shots were taken
i mean
isn't that a subjective question
not if it's in a shot glass it's very
measurable
i feel like that's subjective how is it
subjective you literally pour it in a
glass that's a subjective question why
is it subjective
oh no oh he might be high
[Music]
i'm pretty sure this man is blaze right
now
you're high right now there are there
are three categories right right no i
know
i'll tell you i'm high on life ethan
and other substances
you're definitely not sober i know that
sorry so how many shots were taken i
feel like i'm entitled to that knowledge
um
well i don't know if we really measured
sure yeah i mean they weren't being out
of the box they were just drinking it
out of the bottle yeah okay okay i see i
see that's why it's subjective yeah
okay what else is it's weird right now
too yeah no for sure
what else is subjective in life oh [ __ ]
man
subjective sure what's the subject
do you think god exists
i hope so you hope so why i just you
know i hope when we die we uh we go to a
safe place i guess a safe place yeah i
know science might you know put that
down but i do believe that
we could go somewhere
why do you mean what do you mean science
puts it down well so you know some
people believe that i mean
scientifically we decompose in the
ground right sure so um
what's 69 plus five
you don't ask me
69 70 was 74 yes okay minus five
69 minus five
64.
minus 20.
dude please don't right now
he's definitely high but he might be
crossfaded
dude i'm high on life i'm telling you
are you hungry do you like me to make a
poll for each person as they're up there
for the audience i mean the audience can
yeah the audience can vote for sure look
just for the record my face is always
right
it's always right you're definitely
okay by the way i met uh
chantelle's uh brother next door good
guy yeah guy he's a good guy
does he know what you do to her
what the [ __ ] does that mean
i don't know i just wanted to see your
reaction
you mean
you're talking about
what
i don't know
he's definitely high he might be drunk
too it's a tough one dude i've
where are we all high we're all high on
life he's sweating too boy you are
sweating
can i give my input since i don't know
sure go ahead yeah i don't know i feel
like what do you think zack would do
would zach want to claim that he's drunk
high or both
dude why aren't we all high on life why
are you saying he's both i think he's
he's rock and roll he would take that we
we are on the greatest podcast that ever
exists in the earth
so
so we're high on life okay but you're
also high on other substances
definitely weed
possibly alcohol why are you sweating so
much i see the sweat
i see the beads rolling down your cotton
here dude it's not that hot it's pretty
hot in here it is a little hot
so um tell me about the most traumatic
memory with your debt with todd with my
father yeah
well it's not [ __ ] it's not pod popping
beach balls i'll tell you that it's not
it's worse
it's most traumatic
my dad is the type of guy where he go
out and he
look god love my dad he'll go out and
[ __ ] just not give a [ __ ] he'll go up
to anybody what do you mean go up to
anyone
he'll
just just
he wants people knowing he's there
he's he he wants attention
he likes attention which like i i guess
yeah
which i guess i'm somewhat the same way
no i wouldn't say that not like an
attention [ __ ] no i wouldn't say
would you worry you do worry that you
were like your dad is that something
you're trying not to be i find there's a
lot of tendencies of my father good and
bad right you know right now
you guys should roast each other's dads
i had a running with todd we call him
the taught and talk it was the first
time i met him he's an agent he came
with his he came all tucked up
and he's got a little belly and it was
just tucked up perfectly into a taut and
tuck you know he doesn't wear under he
doesn't wear underwear god help man
i mean
right up in his crotch dude i tell him
every time i tell him every time he goes
out i can see your dick i can see it
maybe he likes that
he you know he is packing he's got that
dad dick yeah
but do you think that he's trying to
show it off not necessarily but why
wouldn't a man wear and then dress pants
and dress pants for christ's sake why
wouldn't you
he just he gets all bunched up that's
what he says i wear undies
i mean sometimes you get punched up but
man you gotta [ __ ] wear underwear
this is society
he goes a full [ __ ] uh john rambo
dude
you say your dad's got a big hog that's
a big guy
and when was the last time you saw it
dude my dad [ __ ] walks around the
house naked now mind you i don't live
with him anymore
but that's naked but ass naked he
doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
bro how when was the last time you saw
your dad's [ __ ]
six days ago are you serious maybe a
little less oh my dude zach's dad is
like seven foot i'm imagining like a
titan from like attack
he's been called thor because he's got
[ __ ] thor's hammer dude the first
time i was talking about his house yeah
i was in the parking i was in this
driveway and saying hi to his dad and
zack walks up he was like dad i could
see your dick through the sweatpants
yeah and his dad's like why the [ __ ] you
looking and i was like oh yeah
for sure
god loved the man but
he's on
so he walks so what is the context of
him walking around naked
he's a free spirit man so you you i know
you have a brother yeah and your mom so
you're all you're like over not he puts
he dresses for chantel right
of course yeah okay just immediate
family so it was just you and your
brother there and it's the weekend
everyone's he just says butt ass naked
well not necessarily like you know
cruising around but like he'll get out
of the shower before he's gonna go in
the shower he uh you know it's a tight
quarters why are you seeing him getting
in and out of the shower he's just
always walked around naked i've never
found it he saw his dinger six days ago
he's like
he's just he just goes man he's proud of
it god bless you know
this is interesting is your mom
objective people are saying mary maybe
isn't that bad what's that name chad's
saying maybe gary isn't that bad after
all there's always someone worse well i
just i don't think it's that weird i
guess i'm used to it do you walk around
naked at your house sometimes
see i don't like being naked i go i like
to i don't like you know what i'm saying
i mean look do you think he just wants
to show off his hog
no i think he's just comfortable right
so i mean i got i got nothing to [ __ ]
be ashamed of
are you saying you have a big hog what
does that mean i i'm i'm blessed yeah
what can i say
all right
congratulations thank you very much
thank you thank you for that intel
um so
family of so you got a big hog
i didn't say that for the record i'm
just i'm you literally volunteered
what i got no shame
all right get is zach he's definitely i
think he's actually crossfaded i have to
say
um well let's put him on the chart this
was going to be a tough one to nail down
the uh the chat poll agrees with you uh
crossfade is at 60 by far
the highest yeah this is real
interesting i really can can i say
something sure go ahead i just want to
thank you for
everything
go on giving me the opportunity when i
was a young
[Music]
oh that you come on let him speak you
gave me an opportunity when i was 21
years old to show you what i'm made of
and i thank god every day that you did
and i love you i really do love you
bring him bring that big old hog over
here
one of the greatest people i've ever met
in my life is ethan thanks like in all
seriousness well you have blossomed into
such a talent when you started
we needed a sound engineer and you
turned into our odd our dj uh and you're
like the soundbite wizard i mean
your transformation back there has been
incredible and i feel like the sound
boards the sound effects is a whole
huge part of the show and that's all
thanks to your mastery
all right
all right take that big hog back sheep
love you too buddy
happy 420.
all right so i'm going to put zach
again i i really thought this was going
to be one of the hardest ones to nail
down but
i'm pretty i'm feeling pretty confident
crossfaded
okay
well that was interesting wasn't it yeah
that went places
all right let's see uh up next
let's bring out um sam let's bring out
sam
sam of course
talented lovely sam
who prepared this game for us and always
looking uh perfect and good
sam welcome
how are you feeling
great okay are you high
that's not that's not the game i feel
like you're just ask
that is the game that i'm i'm here to
ask questions
you just so you can just say are you
high sure
are you
high
oh my god
am i yes
i don't know i don't think so sam tell
me um
how is this 420 going for you
it's pretty good nice good day so far
good day so far are you planning on
seeing the new sonic movie
i no no you're gonna skip that one i'm
gonna i'm gonna sit that one out
you know recovering from the first one
the first one yeah
yeah
um
i smell some kind of peppermint what is
that
um
probably gum oh god chewing gum yeah
everyone everyone everyone was chewing
gum everyone had gum except dan well i
spit mine out before i came back but i
chewed on some me too
sam um
people there are lots of comments saying
you look very good you've been doing
like a diet kind of situation i don't
know if that's related
but people are writing for you in the
comments love sam well thank you that's
very sweet yeah and i have been doing a
diet situation
do you want to talk about that is that
okay uh sure how much weight have you
lost since when uh i've lost 11 pounds
since the beginning of february
super proud of you i know you that
that's just incredible
great job
wonderful how do you feel you feel good
you feel complex proud and accomplished
yeah yeah definitely do you feel high
[Laughter]
no have you seen your dad naked
probably when i was really young not in
my adult life okay good do you remember
anything about his dick no i blocked
that out good for you that's good
yeah i mean
i i'm naked around theodore but like
he's so he's only he's almost three
like we'll go potty together or
or uh he walks in on in the bedroom in
the morning and i might be naked yeah
yeah but at a certain age that's gotta i
don't i don't want him to have those
images in his head right right so
probably around like five or so i don't
know five
what do you think's a good age for him
to stop seeing me naked
hmm 24.
when does like the
when does like the frontal lobe develop
that's a good question can somebody look
that up i actually want i need to have a
strategy for this because i do not want
my poor children have that those
memories i don't think i remember
anything before i was like
seven it says the frontal lobe develops
when you're 25 years old and you should
stop showing you're
going to get five by 25. that seems
really late so i still got another year
dude
you can still get another year i'm
enjoying seeing your dad's [ __ ] amen
dude
amen todd
zach does your dad have a nickname first
[ __ ] i'm sorry to go off topic but i
feel like you should type a dude to have
a nickname for it nah never a nickname
i've given a nickname with my friends
though what's that thor's hammer nice
all right thank you i know too much
about zach's dad yeah we've all learned
too much are you talking about outside
of this interview you know stuff no i
just learned a lot yeah
yeah
so the the poll a lot of people are
saying you're high 62 percent how do you
feel about that
that's very interesting now uh four
percent corrupt said crossfaded i have
to remind you guys
there's just
there's just one of each right and then
no there could be more than one of each
but there's one definitely at least one
of each there's up to two of each right
yeah i will say that we're covering the
full spectrum okay okay got it
um
so okay very good
what's your what are you watching lately
what are you enjoying in life hmm
i haven't really been what's 27 minus 3
24 what's 24 times 3
oh my god
um
i don't know i think it's in
in the 70s range
72 very good
what's 72 minus 21 plus 5
72
minus 21 plus five
oh my god i don't know i'm so bad at
math ethan i think you're high i'm
definitely there with you
um
what are you planning on eating for for
lunch or dinner you got plants crab legs
oh really yeah
do you dip them in something yeah like
um
like a garlic butter oh
how do you prepare the garlic butter
garlic and butter just garlic and butter
straight up do you add salt or anything
or herbs um
the crab is like boiled in
like a
brine with a lot of salt i don't really
think you need to
did you cook the crab no no i'm going to
eat the crab somewhere oh where
the boiling crab is that is that a
restaurant yeah
i've never been there before but it
sounds really good is this a ian idea or
a sam idea
it's a song i'm not invited
oh
is it a girl's thing it is a girl's
thing
hey let's get those crab legs
all right sam i think you're high
uh crazy
it is locking that in
yeah i think i'm gonna i'm trying to i'm
trying to think if there's any more
embarrassing questions
does ian walk around naked
not really yeah not really no
walking around naked is a lot i think
friend it's like does anyone here walk
around naked
zach put your hand down
the only time i do is when i'm waiting
for my hair
because i'm waiting for your hair like
when like lena's bleaching my hair or
something your butt ass naked when she
does it it stains my clothes every time
i'm just in my well why not just wear
why not just i feel like you could wear
underwear yeah you could wear i don't
know
i got some new kelvins i literally
ruined them on friday you shoot their
butt ass naked no he's dying we're
watching uh
we're walking watching peaky blinders
and i was about to speak [ __ ]
what if you get bleach on your dick
that's gonna happen if you don't wear
boxers good point i i like sit in like a
position like this you protect kicked up
in the back aby's got a hog man
what the [ __ ] dude why do you think that
zack i can just tell
you
yeah do you think about that a lot zach
baby's [ __ ] yeah sure
thoughts baby he's my work boy i i think
i have big dick energy but no i have a
small [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so you're saying you exude the energy
but in actuality
nothing nothing impressive yeah just
misleading i disagree
well he's you okay okay well you guys
are gonna have to sort that out
sorted out you guys sort out
and let us know
okay so ian doesn't walk around naked do
you
no not really yeah we have too many like
windows oh so it's really hard if you
had privacy would you walk around naked
yeah probably butt ass naked yeah it's
my house
interesting
but like yeah out of the shower but like
on this lazy saturday your butt ass
naked no i i would probably yeah it
would be like a after shower or
something like that situation not just
like
because yeah you know not like nudist
[ __ ] not like todd [ __ ] yeah yeah like
bernstein [ __ ]
your family's [ __ ] bro
yeah
love them though
or at least i love you i can't speak for
you
i love you too thanks buddy all right
sam
um
do you want to tell us an embarrassing
story
hmm oh
i don't uh
i don't know if i necessarily have an
embarrassing story
i had one about my dad
okay when when you were talking uh to
zach okay this is it okay this is a
sweet story so
when i was younger
i was on the school bus and the school
bus hit a squirrel
and i got home and i was really upset
about it it hit a squirrel it hit a
squirrel a big squirrel how do you how
did you know a school bus hit the
squirrel i was on the bus you saw it and
the squirrel ran in front of the boat
okay and did you you just concluded like
that thing's dozed oh no it was dead
yeah it was for sure dead okay but i got
home and i was so upset about it and my
dad was like
where
so
i was like i was up the street so he
went and he picked the squirrel up
and he had it taxidermied and wow still
have the squirrel to this day
wow
that is sweet and weird
i thought it was very wholesome but a
taxi i thought you guys would maybe bury
it no it's stuff hanging right so what
did you what was your thought as a child
when your dad presented you with this uh
cadaver
i thought it was so sweet really yeah
that is really devastated about the
squirrel
but you realize it was still dead right
yeah but it's now i could literally go
home and like pet it right now
you're gonna have to send us a photo
wait
is that is that the squirrel in the
basement it is the squirrel on the side
so you've seen this i've seen this crap
what was your what what was your
thoughts when you saw that squirrel for
the first time in i didn't know that
that was the squirrel
that's a legendary squirrel right there
we're going to need photos can we get
this okay i'll text my mom and tell her
to send me that's incredible is your dad
usually that sweet and thoughtful
that's like
like that's southern that's country
wholesome that's country [ __ ] oh yeah uh
city slickers don't get it no
folks just don't get it
is your dad uh a big boy
what do you mean like
is he fat oh yeah yeah yeah yeah is that
a southern thing
uh
i mean i guess obesity is higher there
yeah so i would i would say
don't i only ask because i know like if
like the southern thing is like fat and
nice
oh yeah yeah i mean what does he get
down with what does he eat
what does he eat he loves krispy kreme
oh
wow i love that's tough
i want blueberry cake krispy kreme so
bad you're having diet cravings oh yeah
yeah for sure well i feel like i've
known you've been high for a minute now
the way you're talking about food and
stuff
um
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna put you on high
actually there's twenty percent saying
you're sober which is interesting but i
don't see second place yeah i don't see
it thank you sam for sitting here and
enduring
my question here
what do you got what do you think baby
hi
definitely
uh
yeah i think high i think high
i mean she talked about food first she
goes about on about the crab legs yeah
with the butter sauce
and then she goes into crisp oh i need a
krispy kreme right now yeah my girl is
hi
i've seen sam drunk she's i mean sam's
always funny it's a different vibe yeah
she's hilarious
all right so so far
we have cam dan and ian left let's bring
out ian
ian is forced to interact with me
how do you feel about that you look
drunk this dude is drunk right now
have a cdn what are you afraid of ian
don't be afraid ian
so ian you're being forced to interact
with me
that's right uh how does that feel to
sit next to me and uh have to talk to me
it feels good feels good nice thank you
for saying that yeah
so how big's your hog since we're on the
topic
you don't know you don't have to answer
that by the way
i'll show you after the show okay why
not now i'm live [ __ ] it
well we'll get demonetized i know the
game man come on ian's a shower and a
grower
take that for what it is wait what why
do you say that a.b
because it shows
and look at this switching it grows hold
on i want to call attention to that
right there
there we go what are you afraid of ian
there's a big man
so you don't seem sober right off the
bat
but i don't know if you're high or drunk
so we're going to investigate are you
going to be seeing sonic 2 without sam
or is it kind of together or not at all
i don't know the lore
the sonic lore well we never finished
the first one
so they're you're not
yeah i don't know i'm sure there's a lot
of like going into the second without
knowing that information you'll be lost
right the plot is too thick yeah it's
too you know
it's too much okay that's fair enough
yeah and do you what you what's your dad
like i know your dad is english tell me
about your dad
well that's red flag right there
no he's um
he's jacked oh right he's like an
athlete right he's like a reverse me
which is interesting
you know he comes in you what what's
going on rav
really super english you got all the
vernacular down yeah you know he's like
what's for breakfast beans on toast mate
does he ever say bruv for real no he's
never said bravo but we have had beans
on toast many times do you like that or
do you find it odd it's kind of good
okay yeah like
i want everyone to tr like everyone
hates on it but you gotta give it a shot
just like some heinz baked beans
some classic toast i guess i've never
tried it so okay granted but you're
talking about
sweet baked beans on white bread
i just i i just can't even
i can't even forgive the english for
thinking that up yeah and then for to be
universally adopted in the whole country
is unforgivable and i'm sorry i'm sorry
but that's just nasty
look at this oh my mouth is watering
right there look at it so you like like
a nice crispy thick cut of rustic bread
is that the vibe maybe you want to press
f yeah i don't know what input is that
go ahead and hit f12 if you want to pop
that open
f12 god damn it f12 the key
[ __ ] ap
av
f12 what is f12 let's see if it's open
that'll open this dan's computer this is
dan's computer it's on the right input i
just checked wait hang on
we not be able to press f12 at this
moment i think it's up oh okay that's
all we're good yeah we're good f12 is up
so what kind of bread is ideal for you
when eating i think you've got to hit
the white bread if you hit the wheat
bread
yeah that's there's something wrong but
like a thick rustic cut or just like
wonder bread
they usually have really like crunchy
bread right and nice and things that
would tear up the roof of your mouth
yeah something that'll
it'll fit those beautiful pearly whites
they got over there in the uk
get a real good crunch going
do you is your dad's teeth [ __ ] up or
normal no he actually has great teeth
well there you go surprisingly
do you find the english that stereotypes
true that english people have [ __ ] up
teeth
funnily enough like the people i know
um
the brits i know no
yeah no
no we're they're anomalies really so
anomalies with perfect enamel
yeah but my dad he was a very did you
like that play on words
thanks bro
my dad was an intense guy he's an
intense guy 60 saying drunk that's very
interesting because i was feeling the
same thing
what gives you that
i can smell it on your breath
we all had gum i don't know what you're
talking about
tell me about your dad he's an intense
guy
yeah he's like a football hooligan
soccer who likes oh wow okay
yeah i'm like the 60s and 70s so he's
really good at soccer
he was good yeah
what did he compete like in a serious
yeah he um
his first trip to the united states was
to compete in a tournament he flew over
here wait was he playing
professional no no no no but it was some
sort of school tourney thing tourney
thing and so he flew over here and then
how did he end up like uh to live here
he was backpacking uh around the states
and then he actually he met my mom in
some bar in ventura oh no way yeah he
was uh
he was actually scheduled to do a road
trip to south america then following day
and then he actually he met my mom in
the bar the night before and he called
off his road trip wow
etc etc you know the drill wait did they
conceive you like during that no no no
it was later it was later
a few days later
a few days few months and so your dad is
basically
so he's an athlete he's a hiker he's an
englishman
yes
and then your parents came here they
fell in love yes
and um what does your dad do for a
living now
he works at uh ski resort he does all of
the um right
the painting and things like that oh
he's like a service man at a ski resort
he's like in charge of all of the uh
sort of painting and maintenance on on
the lodges and things is he a skier
uh he's a snowboarder now he's oh my god
this guy is like an extreme athlete he's
a mountain biker he's a snowboarder he
he got me into this thing called snow
skating oh i tried that you wait really
it's the one time i went skiing it's my
bad idea no that's what i'm saying i had
the most traumatic i went with my
friends who are like experienced skiers
yeah
they said yo we're going to do this
thing called snow skiing
they're tiny little skis and it's much
harder right oh no no okay that's
different but that's actually you did
that yeah how did that go for you it was
horrible i mean and then they're like
they i went down the bunny slope once
and they're like all right let's go do
some real [ __ ] and they took me down a
black diamond like i don't know if
they're trying to kill me
i literally like crawled my way down the
mountain because i was so terrified yeah
i've never been in the team that's
definitely they were trying to take you
out i'm like why are you guys doing this
to me
why did you bring me on this trip it was
horrible snow skating is like a um
it's like a skateboard deck
oh okay and you don't you don't strap in
why there's a little ski on the bottom
and you throw the skateboard deck down
you just jump on it
and you you tie it to your leg so if you
fall off it like shoots down but then
you reel it back in with a with a whoa
yeah
he loves that [ __ ] he's definitely it's
more extreme it sounds like he's
snowboarding yeah does it make you feel
some type of way that your dad is like
this incredible like this extreme
athlete
i'm sure it feels some type of way for
him when he looks at me he's like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing is your
brother athletic like your dad or no uh
he's a little bit it's definitely like
he's in the middle okay and you're on
the bottom oh yeah yeah yeah and your
dad always trying to get you do like
sports and stuff and you're like no dad
he'd get me to do some stuff um you know
we'd go to the gym together he'd be like
what mate
that's all you can do
you know stuff like that that's not his
real accent no it's it's a little it's
strong but it's not that let me see your
eyes you have beautiful eyes did you
know that you have like yellow
kind of hazel yellow eyes they're like
hazel oh [ __ ] beautiful that's like
edward cullen the bad omen
thank you why is that a bad oh wait who
ed oh like uh twilight yeah
yeah i just noticed you have beautiful
eyes if i could add my input go ahead f9
if you will f9 thank you ian has been
looking at himself a lot in the
reflection and ian never does that he's
been looking at himself on the screen a
lot so what do you conclude from that i
i say i've i'm checking my like lord
farquaad haircut
right now
well actually since we've talked the
drunk has gone down by two percent i
still think he's drunk
some people say sober not sober
i think i do think he's drunk what are
your thoughts ab
yeah i mean if i had to guess i'd say at
least drunk how much did you drink back
there because you don't seem like drunk
you feel you maybe seem like a little
tipsy hypothetically
i wouldn't know right but what are you
afraid of one thing i do know
is this gentleman is faded zach zack is
[ __ ] up there's no question about that
what's up he's crossfaded what's up he's
cross-fading us right oh baby look at
this guy
i'm having i'm missing out right now i'm
getting fomo we need to party dude you
come down the alley after the show yeah
let's throw up let's take a look at the
cards for a few minutes
i got i want to talk to you in the alley
the cool kids hang out huh all right so
um
what's the vote what's the vote going to
be
what what's the matter you end up you're
in a hurry to get out of here what are
you afraid of you know what sucks
is
i do have to go pee
and you guys have ruined that for me
oh please play him off guys
play him off
[Music]
i got a piece so bad
i was trying to switch to you i don't
know your input i'm sorry
ian is drunk come on mom there's no
question
in my opinion and the piece solidifies
it
because you guys didn't come in that
long ago and that dude got to run to the
bathroom i don't know what he's afraid
of he's afraid of something what are you
afraid of ian
all right last we have dan and cam
one of y'all is sober that's interesting
to me
um
wow who's more likely to be sober dan
or cam
dan's a hard one to read
so is cam actually
let's bring out dan and see if we can
get a
a read on the fellow
so one of these two is definitely sober
that's interesting
only if all of your other predictions
were right though
uh none of those guys were sober i'll
tell you that okay okay dan's gonna come
are you gonna come
no
i'm gonna come
thank you dan for sitting with us yep
pleasure to be here right off the bat i
think you're high you're doing a lot of
[Music]
this you must have smoked a lot back
there because it's hard to phase you
well i do have a higher tolerance than
many in this office admit um it takes a
little bit to phase me
yeah
and um
um let's see here what do you know about
my dad yeah what's your dad like
i was gonna ask have you seen your dad's
[ __ ]
uh not since i was a little kid what do
you remember about it i don't really
remember
i know that that was a thing that
probably happened at some point yes but
no man i saw dan's dad like he was oh
you met him well not really but i saw
what he looked like what does he look
like saw his [ __ ]
you saw his [ __ ] he's a handsome jen i
gotta say he was well of course he is
look at danny he's beautiful dan's a
[ __ ] stud but we were when we were at
the concert he facetimed dan and i'm
like oh [ __ ] it's your dad oh that's
right well you facetime your dad at a
concert that's so sweet well he he was
calling me and we were like in the crowd
it's at the gizzard concert the other
yeah last week what was it he wanted to
say he's actually traveling right now so
he was uh just checking in to say hey
wow what a sweetheart he's over in
europe i'm seeing weed uh smoke uh blow
in the background oh yeah dude
did you do a dab
[ __ ] no
respect to the people that do that i i
have done that once in my life and even
though i i've smoked for a long time
that was way too much tell me about
times where you got too high
uh well that was one for sure yeah and i
i decided that that was not for me
um
i don't know i mean when you get too
high you don't really remember a lot
remember we went on a camping trip for
fourth of july once like a bunch of
friends
i think yeah and yeah it was fourth of
july
and we all smoked in a tent like
hotboxed it with like i don't know it
was like 12 people it was like one of
those big tents
and um yeah that can
really get you you just sit there in the
fume yeah it's just like just bacon do
you start to feel like paranoid and
stuff when you get too high
yet anxious i guess is the right term
yeah
but i mean generally i handle it pretty
well but some you know you can continue
yeah that was
i mean
10 years ago at this point so wow long
time
oh someone's got to make a pulse out
there it's high come on this guy's blitz
do you usually do some kind of
celebration on 420
i mean i used to grow you too old for
that yeah kind of i mean we're doing
something now today for the show yeah i
mean it's it's been a couple years but
but respect to the people that do you
know are you hungry what do you think
planning for dinner
i haven't thought that far ahead you
haven't thought that sam yeah
i'm playing these things impulse
are you gonna cook are you gonna order
food
i'm gonna cook something really what's
in the fridge
actually not a lot right now so i
probably will just order something okay
okay okay
and uh people are saying you might be
sober
i don't know i don't think so you guys i
think dan is
blessed are you to be watching what do
you do at night you're going to be
playing some elephant rings you're going
to be playing video i'm watching uh the
attack on titan fourth season let's go
yeah
you're enjoying it right really good
yeah i i'm enjoying it more than i
expected i i've liked the show i wasn't
like super crazy about it but this last
season
took an interesting turn and i've been
enjoying it great the last season was so
good
and are you done with eldon ring are you
still playing that are you i'm pretty
done i beat it a second time with the
second character and i was like i'll
come back i'm good there'll be dlc you
know i'm still playing that [ __ ] yeah
you're like level 300 or something all
right i'm about to get i'm about to beat
it my third or fourth time now
so i've got i'm pretty i'm just coming
to zach and zach is just [ __ ] zombie
let me see
[Laughter]
are you there silly
i've never heard a sound bite in a while
hello
dude he is zonked the [ __ ] out you i'm
surprised you held it together so good
for us yeah
i held it
together i mean kind of better than just
sitting there catatonic
okay so your dad
so you don't know if your dad has a hog
or not what what uh what is this is
interesting about your dad
what's interesting about him um
you know he went to college to be a mime
oh my god i know another dad who's a
mime no way but he's a very odd man is
your but your dad doesn't seem that odd
no he's not odd he's he's a pretty
normal guy uh he he i don't think he
worked professionally as a mime but he
was a very someone to want to be a
professional mime
um i mean he was a very eccentric young
man and had you know he was uh he was
the middle child of three boys
and was definitely the uh the rebel son
um you know i think he had a period of
time where he's estranged with his
parents uh my grandparents but by the
time i was alive it was all good and
normal
well he can't be that bad of a dude if
his rebellious fame is is becoming a mom
right yeah yeah at uh emerson uh college
how is that you can get a degree in mime
dumb and pantomime yes
so he does all this
yeah i mean
is he good at it have you seen him do it
no
he's all right he's all right he's not
even that good at it it's been a long
time he's been a long time that's
awesome this was like when he was like
18. and i think he ended up dropping out
and moving to california which is how he
wound up here he was hippie hippie dude
right right san francisco
you think your parents ever had a
threesome or anything
oh not
probably not i mean free spirits i think
they're uh yeah i mean
maybe
maybe earlier in their life yeah yeah
yeah yeah man god bless
do you think your dad's ever had a
threesome
um
i don't know he's like just asking he'll
tell you todd won't hold anything yeah
you know he will be honest with you then
he said he seems like a key party kind
of guy that's like
it's like a swinging thing
i said that this weekend he does because
there were a bunch of old folks that
went to like a pre-pass over seder and
i'm like did you guys have a fish bowl
key party oh wait what's a fishbowl keep
party what's all these terms it's where
you dan you want to explain it
uh well i think it's just they
uh people go to a party and they put
their keys in a bowl and then you
randomly pick them and then you like
that's how you like pair up yeah what
happens if you fi you don't want what if
you pull the [ __ ]
mon the ogre
the [ __ ] fest dude you get what you get
me don't get upset
anything that moves if you're
participating in an official bowl party
it's a [ __ ] shrek ogre [ __ ] face it
takes place in the swamp that's right
dude so is that um
so dan at the moment 50 are saying hi 36
percent are saying sober that's the
lowest level of confidence of any of
these polls everybody else was around
60. yeah no no i agree
dan's high on life man i'm fairly
confident you're high though i i i feel
like i i could tell yeah okay tell me
about your mom
uh
what about her
does she
is she uh
what's one interesting thing about your
mom
uh she's a writer for children's
animation she wrote a bunch of cartoons
that probably a lot of people watching
this show grew up watching muppet babies
she was muppet babies she's still active
uh she's like semi-retired right now uh
she she gets sucked in for gigs every
once in a while
but um is she is she because
i probably at the top echelon you do
really well in terms of compensation
but i know writers in hollywood are
generally in animation particularly
it's yeah um
yeah it's not great um
not that our family struggled by any
means i mean at times they did you know
both my parents were freelance so feast
and famine yeah exactly um but uh you
know we did well and by the time
she there's a story editor as a position
in uh
that
field and that's like a
you call a head writer i guess and she
did that for a few shows and that's very
pretty that was when the family was
doing well nice she worked on one of my
favorite shows correct me if i'm wrong
then jj the jet plane yeah
i think so don't worry wait what shows
did she work on give us a list
uh she uh
uh she worked on um clifford the big red
dog wow
that was the one she was a story editor
on so wow but yeah a lot of that kind of
stuff like um younger kids between like
like about theodore's age honestly oh
yeah very cool it's a lot of that kind
of stuff but your dad also worked with
her didn't he
yeah he worked in that field as well on
the muppets they were a team actually so
they both like co-wrote on that show
they had the same job
yeah it came about because my dad was
working for marvel animation just as
like a producer or something in the 80s
and the guy who like kind of created
that muppet show ended up quitting and
they were like desperate for people
and my parents were together my mom was
right how they met no they i think they
were already together oh interesting
yeah
but yeah my mom was a writer so and he
knew the show because he was working on
it and so they wrote a spec script and
pitched it and they really liked it and
ended up there it is
wait do you have siblings dan you have a
younger sister i didn't i i
well well tell me about her we don't
know anything about your younger sister
does she watch the show uh no but um her
fiance i know does on occasion so what
up what up patrick patrick you better
[ __ ] be watching this right now
she hasn't watched her show is it not
her type of content yeah i don't think
so
she probably sees some stuff because of
him but and what kind of stuff does she
watch
what kind of stuff does she watch golden
girls
daddy call me daddy she watches all
kinds of stuff i don't know
she call me daddy girl no she's she's a
disney girl she goes to disneyland like
she's one of those people that goes like
my brother my brother does that yeah
you know for my brother's uh
birthday i got him and his fiancee
seasoned tickets
right that's one thing that's like they
go like every week man
it doesn't go quite that often but she
goes a lot yeah i wish i loved something
like they do you know they go it's like
great it's like how many times can you
go to that totally honest with you right
now please we were going to go to disney
recently when you was in town or
whatever
in my heart i was kind of like you
didn't even want to go i mean
of course it would be fun and it's going
to be fun to go but we were just there
like a year like i need a little more
time right the [ __ ] more time to miss it
no i i get you totally
all right dan well
i understand people saying sober you i
think you are high but you you carry it
very well
obviously
and i am going to say watch cam cam's
going to come out after you be totally
[ __ ] like blitzed
and then i'll know you are sober no but
i'm going to say you're i'm going to say
you're high
and uh i accept that
and that's that's what i'm going to go
with i think i think high as well you
think that yeah what do you what do you
think about why why are you going high i
just i'm getting uh that he's not in the
normal state of mind even though he's
playing it off well but i'm not getting
drunk vibes i feel like he's not drunk
yeah the thing is he's i got a little
bit of of nervous energy from dan
especially when he first sat lots of
tapping kind of tapping on the mic which
is bad etiquette which he knows better
yes i do know better that's not
necessarily well
i'm just i think it's so much i'm
fidgety i'm a fidgety guy love you think
he's sober
yeah
yeah he's doing the reverse he's acting
a little he's not acting come on
he's not coming out here and pretending
to be
you think he's pretending to be high
then you think he's hot yes that's what
he did last time i think no
did you act last time dan well he didn't
act but you assumed he was sober when he
was actually yeah i think he's a little
bit shitty i think he's being a little
bit cheeky um all right let's bring out
cameron let's set up that paul
cameron our last uh crew member
is coming out
he's in his bunny form
is this what's the what is this bunny
form you're in cam
cameron is very nice we uh we got this
in the mail
this was uh somebody sent this and i
just kind of leaned into the meme at
this point what's the emblem i think
it's what do you guys know what it is
back in the booth there oh it's so you
don't you know who's who sent it to us
uh are you guys back in the booth there
no i have no idea actually i think it's
either like achievement hunter or
something like that i just i just like
it because it's bunny okay interesting
well welcome
the voice of the bunny behind us welcome
cam thank you very much
i'm already getting high vibes
which means that i [ __ ] up something
what makes you say that the eyes are a
little glazed is it really okay
interesting but obviously i could be
wrong it could be the lights i mean you
have a big bright light shining in your
face well you thought i was high the
last time and you were sober right yeah
exactly so i think i'm a bit of a wild
card but you saying that
means that you're [ __ ] hide
potentially yeah i mean potentially it
could be what's left here oh you're
blaze bro your eyes are so watery did i
[ __ ] it up with dan no i don't know
maybe i was crying back there i'm not
sure the rules of this game i don't know
i don't know
where's the pole where did dad go dan's
in the bathroom so take that forward
what do you make of dan going off to the
bathroom already
maybe he's drunk maybe you got him all
pegged wrong what'd you get
i said he's high he said he's high he
could be drunk he's going pee pee
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story so
does your dad have a hog we're learning
about dad's here today my dad is in not
to be a buzzkill but
he's in heaven i hope but he's in heaven
yeah okay yeah well i'm sorry to hear
that what happened uh what happened with
your dad
uh
right now
yeah to be
no it's fine i mean like i just wanted
to learn about his dick i mean [ __ ] if
you don't want to talk about it
no i i i want to learn i
and and i okay if you're comfortable
talking about it i am comfortable and so
don't feel bad okay oh yes but my dad uh
overdosed on heroin oh wow so yeah wow
i'm very sorry to hear that yeah so yeah
that's yeah so what did your dad always
kind of struggle with drugs throughout
your life or where did that come from
well it was kind to be honest with you
it was a complete uh blind sight
really yeah you didn't even know he had
uh nobody knew whoa yeah it was he it
started
he had an injury
and then that started as a oxycontin
gosh
yeah so it was like a progression from
there but whoa yeah but you didn't know
so like you know and i you know yeah
no yeah uh well first of all thank you
for sharing well i mean you know i've
had lots of time to process it so you
know how long ago was was uh i was 12
years old so it's been a long time oh
okay yeah yeah
are you do you hold any resentment to
like
purdue and all these companies that push
oxycontin certainly yeah i mean well
like yes and i think it's it's it's
difficult to say because he was
genuinely injured at a time what was the
injury that he suffered uh he
got into a car accident and he messed up
his knee okay okay point of like you
know almost being in composite
incapacity and it's incredible they went
straight to oxia yeah yeah and i mean he
was he was like disabled for a while he
was suffering yeah he needed something
you think exactly yeah but there's got
to be less
addictive drugs you know certainly yeah
i mean well i i guess i'm not in the
medical field but sure
yeah
yeah
so do you think because there's actually
lots of lawsuits going on now with
purdue they're actually i think they're
going bankrupt and [ __ ] because they're
having to pay out so much to victims are
you following that case not at all
actually yeah something to look into for
sure yeah
yeah well that's very sad i'm very sorry
i guess that's sorry to be a buzzkill
about it no we're learning about dads
here yeah exactly better or worse dads
and i i i loved him a lot did you watch
a suicide squad at all
the movie the movie yeah yeah like you
know jared leto's finest
no the second one that came out sure oh
the suicide squad that was the new one
it just came out yes exactly i thought i
you know i related a lot to the la the
rat lady character because her father as
well was like a beloved
guy in her life
and he just you know the demons got the
best of them in that and you know same
same story too so you were very close
and had a loving relationship with them
yes very close yeah wow yeah
wow yeah it's sorry to be a buzzkill
people you know no no no it's okay to
talk it's not your fault we don't have
to talk about the you know we talk
don't feel bad it's not about god i
don't feel bad you know yeah this is
what it is but yeah and so tell me
how
do you have siblings i have a sister
yeah
so that must have hit the whole family
pretty hard when that happened yeah yeah
it was pretty rough it was pretty rough
wow and that being 12 years old being so
close to your dad
yeah and like that was a rough time man
like you know i've obviously come out on
top you know i'm good now but
uh
yeah he was uh you know because like
puberty was right around the corner and
so it was a lot of emotional distress at
that time
but you know i came out on top like i
say
do you blame those blunder years photos
on the trauma or was that just a bad is
that just the style i think it was i
think well
i was looking for an identity at that
point and you know i was grabbing on
anything and you know blunder years for
sure
uh played a role in that by the way i
don't know if you guys know but cam is
like one of the top posts of all time on
blunder years i don't know if you guys
can find that yeah but cam showed us one
of his old photos and we i think we
suggested right to post that the blunder
years boom it went right up it was one
of those uh cringe story segments and i
shared the photos with you guys right
you encouraged me yeah you guys got to
find that post on blunder years yeah
lots of love and support for you in the
chat obviously i love the love and chat
so thank you very much guys
what did your dad do for a living he was
you know ironically enough he was a
corrections officer at a medium security
prison yeah wow can hit anyone yeah i
guess so yeah
where was he getting like the heroine
from did you guys ever figure that out
no idea yeah i have no idea about that
but
man
and what happened did they cut off the
oxycontin or or did he just need like a
stronger hit
um
i think i think
he did
like eventually get off the prescription
of it
and he just needed a strong something
stronger to sustain that wow
yeah
ah such a demon you know what the it was
such yeah dude if there's any substance
that's like straight out of hell it's
heroin right that's right
the best you'll feel in your life by you
know simultaneously taking away
everything else you know i've taken like
some minor opiates in my life nothing
close to heroin you know like tram at
all which is like you know a thousandth
of the potency sure
and when you come down from that high
you feel so bad like i and that's just
from terminal like you can't sleep
you're uncomfortable you're having heat
waves
i can only imagine
how horrible it would be to come off of
something like that i have no idea and
i've stayed you know on yeah somewhere
in the straight and narrow since but you
know well love to you and your family
well love to you and your family you
know that's that's horrible i'm sorry
about that well you know i'm sorry to
bring it up but you know i you know it's
such a beautiful segment here that i
hate to you know take away this is
beautiful i mean i'm happy to learn
about you and for you to open up it's
not uh
there's nothing wrong with that
well thanks for having me on
i'm not done with you okay yeah
uh cam tell me about uh your mom
uh she's retired now she was a special
education okay
and um
very good she's retired very good what
does she do to pass the time uh she
teaches pottery part time wow she's an
artist as well is she good with does she
have crazy pots better than me yeah for
sure yeah does she do so i see like seth
rogan doing [ __ ] is what he does like
impressive or i love seth rogens
personally so does she do crazy pottery
like that or is it more traditional more
traditional yeah seth rogens is pretty
on guard it's pretty abstract but i love
i love this stuff yeah it's real
interesting right
so are you good with pots have you ever
tried to do pottery stuff i've always
been more digital based i guess yeah i i
kind of get a weird sensory thing when
doing the wheel right right right yeah
all right cam i've learned i've learned
enough thank you for sharing where you
think i am you're definitely high you
think i'm high yeah okay definitely
interesting oh you might be drunk i
could be you know i could be sober as
well you're not sober i can tell in the
eyes this is the eyes that gives it away
your eyes are from the moment you sat
down very watery and slanted okay and
squinty i mean i'm always kind of you
know smiley and you know
what do you think baby what do you think
abe he's kind of
i'm not sure
you're not sure
this is by far the most divided on the
audience let's see so we've got
drunk nobody thinks drunk okay sober and
high
that could be a 50 50. this is tough
because nobody's under sober
but dan could be i don't know you could
have got one of these wrong you know why
else would your eyes be so watery and
like gus and and squinty how often do
you look deep into my eyes like this you
know
also he's not used to sitting under all
these bright lights you don't know you
have like the most watery eyes of anyone
who was up here that could be i could
play a fair game well you tell me what
are you saying the people that did smoke
uh did do do like eye drops and
everything too so yeah but that's not
enough okay
yeah i just kind of locked eyes with him
for a second you see what i'm dealing
with this [ __ ] is definitely
high there's that's what i'm saying
like his eyes are so glazed right now
like a damn
like a damn thanksgiving turkey could be
i'm not gonna say all right get out of
here all right thank you for not asking
me math questions because i would have
failed
[Applause]
yeah you can do some shuffling because
if he's high
i think that makes dan sober what do you
think baby
okay i'm not sure the rules does someone
have to be sober yes
the
the
there is somebody that is at least one
of those four categories and then
obviously because there's five there's
there's somebody there's someone that's
sober
uh
yeah dan would be my best guess all
right i'm sticking with this
what do you guys think this is my best
guess because i'm i'm basically
between cam and dan i'm saying
that uh dan is sober people are saying
dan is not sober let's take a pull here
let's take a poll who's hi dan or cam
you guys couldn't you guys didn't we
need a close-up of cam's eyes you know
what i'm saying can we get a close-up
yeah yeah but let's get a close-up of
both those eyes before we you guys vote
you can set that up but i'm telling you
that man is glazed bro
that man is triple glazed
so the poll is between myself and cam
who's high
i'm not getting drunk vibes
anyway cameron i'm glad you shared that
with me you know that that's that's
that's powerful and thank you i
appreciate that no no don't do that
don't do that put them let them down
clockwork
i get it now doctor all right wait come
here baby i got it yeah
go ahead show me the shelves are
okay
see the
oh wait i mean anybody
zoom that in look at
that again
[Music]
look like a cop dan
you guys see those eyes of cameron's do
you see what i'm talking about his eyes
look like hamburgers
sober as a golfer yup
well dan being sober would be the
curveball in 420 because he's the most
prolific smoker
[Music]
and then i would maybe move how often do
you smoke cam
uh
multiple times every week
okay so you you're a regular smoker yeah
they're very much a frequent flyer
and then
people who did smoke can you tell me how
much you smoked
well there's no way to do that
it's going to give it one marijuana yeah
one uh
exactly one one unit of marijuana
briefers
people are saying sam sober hell no
that girl is blitzed
people are saying sam is sober
hell no
she's she's nodding her head no to me
are we getting a shot of sam's eyes yeah
it's too dark you need that glisten
wait let me bring the camera hold on
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we gotta lock it in we gotta
lock it in let's vote so you guys think
it's dan or cam and i mean uh that's
based on the eyes alone
i think i made the right choice the poll
is saying 73 cam
dan is sober as a gopher man
all right i'm feeling really good about
this i think i might get a hundred
percent
last year i had a few wrong
but i'm feeling really good about this
so without further ado let's let's
reveal
the status what's the best way to do you
want to just go i'll just go one by one
okay
i'll call it out all right
zach was brought out
and promptly started discussing his
father's [ __ ]
give us some give us some hype music
here yeah for the review come on you
yeah
so i'm gonna say
and i'm feeling very confident
that zach why the [ __ ] is this okay this
way damn it
[Music]
that zach is both
oh my god you guys i'm losing it
[Music]
okay this is good because i wanted to
face yeah maybe make it a little wider a
little wider just a hair
i can't even see
zach
we voted
uh after learning about your dad's hog
that you are crossfaded both high and
drunk zach what is your status
wait what the [ __ ] what is this story
are you high bro
go ahead
i'm drunk as a skunk [ __ ] and
you're wrong oh
no wait you're still drinking
[ __ ] yeah dude jack jim daniels is my
best friend of course i've known jack so
long i call him jim i might cut his mic
soon dude zach is turning into a
liability that's a protective oh my god
come on
dude jack daniel's my best friend
before we started take that away from me
zach's like i'm going to need you to
watch over me for this you need to be my
dad but after learning about his dad
yeah you want to be a dad and
immediately goes abu's got a hug i know
it dude baby i know he's got a [ __ ]
monster
to make you uneasy that he's thinking
about the size of your [ __ ] or i love
baby it's not as exciting
it's not as yeah it comes up a lot it's
not a sexual thing it's it's a little i
believe you i believe you that it's not
a sexual thing not that i care
it is interesting just took the bottle
away give me the ball back dad
not a good sign not a good sign when you
start fighting for the bottle um but
yeah i'm uh do you want me to give a
speech or something like
sure i
you're wrong
all right i'm uh i'm pretty [ __ ] up
right now on alcohol
well first of all i gotta i gotta give
props to zach because he actually went
all in the man is trash i'm [ __ ] like
who's crossfaded who can i say who's
crossfaded if not zach nobody went for
the damn thing you know man i'm on silly
zonka and booze right now but zilizanka
just comes from my my brain right that's
that's the mental illness now i think
cam is crossfaded
right golly you might be right
this is hard this is hard
all right well down one
[ __ ]
pass that bottle i'm ready to turn up
dude that bottle is gone
you finished
it's not completely gone no i saw
somebody
maybe what did you drink zach
a lot
holy god oh my god well i'm glad your
girlfriend also works here so you know
how his ass is getting off i got a ride
home dude don't worry yeah but uh
you laugh like a drunk dad
how many shots you think you had today
[ __ ] dude i don't even know man [ __ ]
yeah i'm just [ __ ] that bottle that
bottle is my best friend dude you know
when you got nothing else in life so we
actually we water that down sack there's
not a lot of alcohol in there
so how often does he ask talk about your
dick maybe
he refers to it as a juicer or a hog
quite often oh my god look takes one to
no one man
you got a hot what is it about abe that
you think he's got a hog he's a stud man
what can i say he's got that big dick
energy
all right
yeah
i think when god made it
good looking people he's like let's give
him a big dick they get it all yeah it's
you know wait are you now do you accept
the title of good looking maybe i seem
so no no i just seems like you just
acknowledged yourself
hey hey
but i'm the heartthrob [ __ ] that
that's not true though i am the
heartthrob now
no there was one official poll
abey did win the title zack to be fair
i he did win the title of harvard you
know in my head
and in my being
i'm still are you doing it donald trump
you did like
all right zach you're drunk we get it
thank you love you
i would drink but i don't know how i'm
getting home also i got kids yeah yeah
done ela's going to be pissed i got a
guy
i got two dogs at home i got kids too
man you know it's how it is i gotta roll
maybe zach is drunk thank you
moving on
[Music]
to the high
now sam sat before us
[Music]
she kept it pretty close to the vest
but her her excitement for food
there was a slight glaze of the eyes
led me to believe that young sam
is high sam what is your status
i am completely sober oh my god
this is a disaster
oh no
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
you're sober as a gopher
sober
oh is this ethan
uh
discord the picture of the squirrel
here's the squirrel oh [ __ ] it's like
mounted on a piece of wood yep and that
is a big squirrel
that's cute
they did a really good job for it was
like squished under a bus no it no it
wasn't like uh
deformed in any way
it was intact did you mean more of an
impact uh than uh so would the squirrel
have a name
no i should name him though did you meet
the squirrel's father does it have a
baby what's his dad like i want to meet
that dude that you guys say hog
you don't like that i hate that
what's your preferred uh
uh
pref uh
uh noun for a for a penis just dick is
[ __ ] thick pog is funny i don't know
why i just think it's funny
say that again
actually not juicer juicer refers to
[ __ ] oh come on juicer is a [ __ ] yeah
it's just sure
no it's so you prefer just dick yeah no
extras no actually can you say that can
you wait can you say that again i want
to clean don't say anything exactly
all right let me adjust this actually
damn this this is embarrassing
all right no you're right you're walk in
correct
[Music]
s for sober sam sober
all right i think you're right abe i
think cam might be crossfaded so moving
on to cameron
[Music]
we learned the tragic story of his
father thank you for sharing
but your eyes were glazed
could be and squinty
cameron what is your status
i
am
crossfaded there it is
another l for us
damn dude i mean actually i'll i'll give
it up cam really did i feel like he's
relatively [ __ ] up am i right cam yeah
i mean i've been drinking as much as
well not as much as zach but you know
i've definitely been cam [ __ ] you're
as [ __ ] up as me dude yeah well he's
just not being his expert
i'm a close second i'll say but you know
uh
i i think i can hold my alcohol a little
bit better
i could have if it wasn't for zach being
so belligerent i could have
i maybe could have pegged you i'm uncle
zach dude monkey
yeah
all right so so far i'm basically zero
for like what four three
uh yeah not good
not good all right so moving on to
ian wait we said ian was drunk
be afraid of ian
yeah ian came out he seemed a little
higher spirits than usual
a little more talkative we learned about
his athletic dad
uh he's not seen his dick
that's right no i've seen him not that
you remember
you don't remember right though or was
that a lie you didn't ask me i got lucky
do you remember
yeah and is it a hog or not
what is it uh in the english terms what
is it a bell end bangers and mash he's
got a banger and a banger and mash
dude he uh he knights
called spotted dick why are you making
me say this man yo do they night with
that does a queen knight with your dad's
dick
what's up ian
[Music]
all right zach what is your status no
zach
ian what do you normally i am i'm all i
know i know zach i know i know ian what
is your status
i'm drunk boy yay
i got one right
were you surprised i got you ian you're
the only one i got right so far
i don't know i think i had some telltale
signs yeah yeah i mean you actually you
called he like walked out and
immediately we're like this dude is
drunk okay good see i i know some things
yeah yeah yeah
why'd you have to take a leak so soon
i can't help him he's drunk
didn't drink look i got a piss too but
i'm holding it in oh yeah
why are you guys always gonna shave my
bladder man
all right well hey i'm feeling good
about that
well done well done
all right now the trickiest category
we're moving on to sober
which we learned sam is sober which
means dan
is probably high
we learned about dan's parents that'd be
correct
we learned to confirm it yeah yeah i
thought you were high
i knew your ass was high
i got all turned around you got in your
head dude i got all turned around dan
came out here slapping on the table
banging on the mic
i am fidgety though like that i know
you're busy come on wait is that the
same thing that happened last time
yeah oh wow you got a store
so that's everyone guys everyone
so just to summarize here cameron is
crossfaded dan is high
zach and ian are
drunk sam
is sober sober sober and of course lena
and abe are fasting for ramadan
and ethan is sober as a gopher
we got unfortunately jack daniel's left
do you want some ethan i don't even know
how i'm gonna get home i gotta get home
unfortunately
what is home though what is home it's
the road where my wife will kill me if i
don't end up there in time to help with
the kids
that's where home is
wherever that is can somebody give me a
ride home i am going to get a bum a ride
yeah i got a real talk
yeah thank you very much we're going to
get you home cam don't worry thank you
zach's going to drive you
[Laughter]
dude zac is not driving to be clear his
girlfriend works here
yeah he's not driving but cam it'd be a
wild ride
not good
not good i love
he'd be happy to let you drive we might
get a little wet and wild you know
wet and reckless sweat and reckless yeah
don't worry we'll get we'll get it
reduced
[Laughter]
only ryan cavanaugh can hit and run a
police officer drunk and get a wet and
reckless
just for the i am so [ __ ] like blitz
right now it's insane yeah no i believe
next week or what i know dude i don't
know
you guys enjoyed it huh i don't know if
i'm gonna be able to come to work
tomorrow
well there's no work tomorrow so you're
in good shape right or there's no show
tomorrow no show tomorrow there's always
work oh you gotta work deadbeats we're
on that grind i'm just gonna have to
boot and rally you could take you could
you could sleep in if you got a hangover
i
mean
we'll see how i feel did you were we
able to add the uh habitat for humanity
thing love no not not yet okay send it
to you get cleared with some
confirmation oh just one thing and that
is ryan cavanaugh is the force of nature
ryan kavanaugh does ryan kevin look at
harvey weinstein.com
that is brian cavanaugh as a force of
nature i love that clip so much
i love it this website is beautiful it's
so beautiful
yeah please let's get lo i really want
to add that huge habitat for humanity
thing
oh yeah it's really important next
friday it's going to be up for friday
good
well how long we've been going dan
uh let's take a peep
about two hours 11 minutes we started a
little early today as you guys we're
trying to be doing more often uh from
now on i guess we should when do we
start today at one
so that's pretty good one's not bad
ela wants us to start at 12 30. yeah
yeah i know i think that's a great idea
really is it better wait you guys want
to do the heart dog pull okay [ __ ] it no
no no no no no no no
i'm a hard drive
it was a one and done thing i mean ab1
what's the the announcer for the fight
already knows me as h3 heartthrob it's
just you don't want to lose the title i
mean it was it was it was like a you
know 2020. he's gonna intro you as h3
heartthrob that was one of the things on
the list yeah oh my god dude
now who put that forward ab no i don't
know it's [ __ ] dude thank you love
i'm curious to get a heart throughout
2022 paul
but you're jack i mean how are you gonna
lose i think cam deserves to win cam
with a [ __ ] stud cam could actually
cam is in the running that's true cam's
a [ __ ] stuff i see lots of simping
for cam
what about love love is the real
heartthrob glove has a shot people love
love take that back no i'm kidding
you're about to get introduced as the
former heartthrob
what's that like
apparently it's very painful you know
what dude i'm very content with myself
if you want the heartthrob and take it
whatever i know i i know i'm exactly
brought that on himself i know look no i
did not you brought that i i know i'm
i'm i'm very content with myself i have
a yeah
yes so
therefore i am the heartthrob in my life
there you go [ __ ] you
but if you recall exactly zach brought
that on himself
he walked in that day right there you
called me you called me the heartthrob
on an episode and the next days that
came in a full suit oh he was over
compensating then we had to do the poll
look a b is a good looking guy look i'm
not very handsome he's very [ __ ]
handsome he's got a hog
but
you know i
look i'm very i'm very content with
myself and who i am we're we're going to
do the poll
we're going to [ __ ] pull it whatever
why this is good this is too good we got
it maybe he doesn't want to lose the
title
zach is going to be absolutely gutted
i think that you've got some dark horses
you got cam and love dark horses both uh
while sam's here you got anything to say
oh ian's not even up for the vote
sam you're not gonna speak up for your
boy anybody you got any names
in your head uh i think it's ian
no
okay it's some support for young
beautiful ian and dan of course trimmed
you're look you must i think you've lost
a lot of weight then you look very good
you look very
yeah you look great thank you
i'm the only one that's a [ __ ]
disaster spirited i don't
you guys are thinking yeah i don't want
to i'm gonna feel bad when i come in
last place i don't want to i don't want
to do it oh okay yeah this is that's
some trouble [ __ ] look what i did to
this point
how about we put how about we put the
people that care
basically it's a b why can't we all be
back
how about i agree with zach if if i lose
i'm ending the stream bro he's just
gonna kill it you're a drunk [ __ ]
right now
people are saying olivia should be in
the heartthrob as well yeah she's gonna
win yeah olivia for sure libya
definitely has uh the most following i
feel like yeah there's lots of love for
olivia that's true
i've been listening
well then you got to put sam and now
everybody feels bad
by the way the poll only lets you do
four things it's just it's not it's okay
let's just do zack and abe then
that is good that's good these two guys
they they need we need to settle this
once and for all
all right zach and abe zach and a.b
who's the heartthrob not of the show
between the two of them right this is
just between abe
and zach heartthrob i don't care who
it's a two-man show zac says he doesn't
care who wins he talks about it every
week i know i have a happy life a b
clearly doesn't care
he's scared to losing the title oh my
god early votes are coming in is not
looking good for you zach
whatever abe how are you feeling is it
that oh my goodness
this is wrong i feel bad for my buddy
again zach listen oh god listen
that's why it's
put those [ __ ] boxing skills with
pass right now
so we're coming in with 5 000 votes 74
a.b
it's a blowout but 26 percent is you
know
if 28
of the women out there are in thinking
or or men or whatever but people think
you're the heartthrob that's a dub dude
what it's going up you're at 30 percent
now i tip my hat table what can i say
i'm not mad
i'm very content with who i am
oh
all right do you want me to cry
no i don't want you to cry but i feel
like you you're the one that called for
this didn't you
am i zack's the one that called for the
vote
i think you're getting sympathy votes
now it's up to 30 percent
he's gonna win the fight [ __ ] brett
he's gonna win
he's gonna win
people are saying it's cam anyway so
there you go
i'm sorry abby
all right there you guys you're happy
you got your ball and now zach is gutted
i feel ashamed he's got it for gracie
this is [ __ ] up
i think the real winner would be the
pete davidson cut out
there we go yeah that's the real
heartthrob right there i [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of that cut out play
i'll make a cutout with my own member
oh yeah i don't even need scissors to
cut that up
team a b though i'm team maybe
people are saying camily camily camille
camely emily
zach you're obviously very handsome
you're very tall thank you
you have a lot going for you so six two
one
musician play guitar yeah you shred come
on
you've got a girlfriend a dog a hog i
have a video
you know what he's beating me on cameo
you're better you've got cameo dubs
i have a very blessed life there you go
don't feel bad yeah you're beautiful man
no you are
all right
you guys want to talk about some goofs
real fast
what's the best story for a suit i
really like this madonna one personally
no let's just do goofs what it's funny
you don't think it's ghosts what do you
want which one do you like we just have
all these like oh goofy-ass thing at the
top at the top the video you said what i
have highlighted is one of the best
videos oh this show okay let's fill that
one
yo this straight up showed up on my for
you page tick tock continues to be the
best social media app undefeated i'm
learning i'm laughing look at this [ __ ]
this showed up on my face
wake
[Music]
one of the things that that i strongly
believe is
i should probably go home
it's time
joe
what's happening
[Applause]
[Music]
this is like a half-life 2 thing hello
i'm not sure mr president
wake up
oh my god
do dude no [ __ ] way dude
that's powerful
you should have to pay nearly sixty four
hundred dollars more than you would
today
is this a fan of our show do you think
or is that just
wally has his own like
and i mean certainly our our show has uh
added to that that's a work of art man
yeah that was amazing at it
i love the when i don't know what but
like
i'm sure a lot of this is out of context
but there's like when joe biden gets
like he like gets startled out of wake
there's like several shots of him like
she's so good
um the chat is
oh the bank story about the bong story
that you promised so right we should do
that all right so when i was about i
think what it must have been 18 years
old
all my life okay i had this i had uh
stuffed animals of all the south park
characters
and in the uh
cartman one
under his beanie
my whole life i've been storing money i
got for hanukkah
for my birthday i would get 25 bucks
here 25 bucks there
and in my whole life i accumulated about
600 bucks in cash
18 years old that was my life savings
that was cheddar cheese
boom life savings pretty good i felt
good about that you know
so i got really into like weed culture
just ridiculously stupidly
into it
despite never liking smoking really
right haven't you explained that no i
was smoking all the time then but it was
like it was a short period of time where
maybe for six months i turned into like
a massive stoner that had like a mental
breakdown and then stopped smoking
but during that six months
i was just blazing getting super into it
and um
one day i was like i think it's time for
me to buy a bong you know
so i can smoke at my house because i was
always going to my one specific friend's
house and smoking there says i need a
piece of my own you know i need to be
initiated into this culture
i need a piece of my own
and at 600 bucks i want to flex on them
actually i didn't even bring the money
back 600 is so just for anybody that's
not initiated into this culture
whatsoever that's a lot of money for a
bong you can get a bong for
i don't know
60 bucks well so we go down to i'm
inventor at the time i'm not even in la
but my friend goes yo we should go down
to
venice beach they got crazy bong's there
it's cool
so one day we drive down there
and we're looking at uh
all the head chops
there's this one bong artist named
jerome baker that like my friends were
super into i don't know if you heard
about this guy dan
no he makes really beautiful glass yeah
he's a black glass blower
jerome baker
he makes really good is he also a
football player a linebacker in the nfl
no no well then i don't know about him
here it is he makes these really kind of
everyone's seen pieces like this they're
like really cool sure
intricate pieces
he signs them
they're really cool
so we go down to this head shop that has
jerome baker pieces
and there's this one piece called the
mothership
it's like the crown jewel
there's some people saying uh they know
who he is so i guess yeah i sent one of
from his instagram
it looks massive oh so like he has
normal like respectable pieces that are
probably you know like 100 bucks
and then he's got the mother ship here
let's see what this one is what now what
the hell is this thing
with my boo
what am i even looking at
well that's a bubbler i think that's
oh so these are yeah these are his
pieces and they're really beautiful the
guy is obviously
a skilled craftsman
now let me show you the mothership
i think this is a name of like a
specific collection he makes
that are like the craziest ones this
bong
that i saw it must have been three or
four feet tall i mean it was like you
hit it standing sure yeah
but not only that the art was really
beautiful it looks you know something
like this this is pretty accurate the
top was all freaking blinged out there's
like really intricate glass work on the
bottom it's a beautiful piece
500 bucks
this is
600 well i don't it was basically my
life-saving sure i basically spent i was
like
it was so stupid because i was like
where the [ __ ] am i going to put this
thing how am i going to use this at my
house like it's not discreet at all this
is what this is just ridiculous but i
get on my head like this is a
collectible dude i'm going to be smoking
my whole life this is a this is going to
last me my whole life this is a jerome
baker do you know what that means
i didn't care i didn't know anything
about it but i got all hyped up into
buying this thing
yeah it's pretty much like this the
mothership baby
and uh so i convinced myself all right
i'm gonna buy this thing you know
so
i'm gonna i'm gonna have it forever
so we go back to my friend's house i
have this big ass case it literally
looks like a gun i don't know it's got
this big case
flip it over your shoulder like you go
like you're pitching a tent
so get back to my hat my friend's house
i'm broke i got no money got a few i got
a little money you know for for a bag
and
um
we bring it up to his room
we're admiring the beauty so beautiful
uh everyone's chilling
i go to fill up the water
come back
we got i'm checking so then
i'm checking the water line right you i
don't know if you don't know how bogs
work you put water in the chamber on the
bottom
and you want it to be like you know half
full because you don't want it to blow
into your mouth when you suck in
but you need enough to submerge the
straw
so that it's filtered through the water
so
exactly
so i'm looking at the water line
and what's actually interesting about my
friend's room is that he's got a ceiling
fan that's pretty low
and so as i'm looking at the water line
like this oh boy i put and because it's
so tall
i put it in the ceiling fan and it goes
pink and it just gets cut right and
[ __ ] half
and it breaks like right here right here
[Laughter]
right here
so the whole top portion goes flying off
in one clean break right here
never used it one time oh my god
that's so tragic and one of my friends
yeah so there was three of us me and my
friend were there and we're like no
[ __ ] way that just happened and then
my other friend went to go get a bag or
something and come back
and he came back and we're like dude
it's broken he's like stop [ __ ] with
me he's like no way you broke it just
like like it's broken dude he couldn't
believe it we showed it
cut in half so eventually we said [ __ ]
it we started we are
literally blazing
out of
the broken base with shard [ __ ] glass
and [ __ ] still used it oh yeah nice
and then his actually my friend's dad
tried to fix it
with like plexiglas he's like a handy
guy
he plexi glassed it it was hideous
though it worked maybe for like a few
days but it was just it turned black and
it was like covered in tape it was just
hideous
that's so tragic so it was the probably
the most expensive thing i'd ever bought
in my life
and probably the dumbest things i bought
in my life sure and it broke before i
even got to use it once and um
that was a life lesson
[Laughter]
and it felt like
it was so much money it was just like oh
so painful
ah
you know
600 for a bong dude
probably took the longest time to make
i can only imagine
you know it's funny because everyone who
like i have family members who smoke a
lot they're like don't buy glass dude
it'll break it always breaks she's got a
plastic bong it doesn't matter
i had to go all the [ __ ] out
and it was a
painful loss a bitter experience for
sure lot of people saying that's
probably why you hate smoking weed
because of that incident pretty sure was
the panic the the uh
existential
panic attacks i had that ruined my life
for like five years
but it could be that
you know
i was the same way i liked smoking for a
little bit and then after that i just
i had bad anxiety attacks i could not do
it
yeah you know what's interesting is all
my friends who are like lifelong smokers
they're all like oh i don't do i don't
even smoke anymore because i just get
all [ __ ] up and get panic attacks so i
don't know
yeah just saying just saying
but like let's be honest this thing
probably
this thing was never going to last
anyway
these things are made to be broken
because you're high
around fragile glass work the shit's
gonna break there's no [ __ ] shot
you know if you're planning on using it
so but there you go
um
there you go
what else we got we have a new wally uh
as is wally coughing or [ __ ] his
pants
let's find out
[Laughter]
is he doing a prayer or like that's not
yeah that sounds like a prayer okay
[Applause]
six people watching it says
he's got so many fans but only six
watching is that because he changes
accounts well he goes yeah he changes
accounts every few months after they get
hacked or he gets uh taken off people
hacking
i don't know why that's so funny yeah
people are [ __ ] crazy and he goes
live all the time too he sleeps on
camera a lot just goes live and just
falls asleep doses off love that
so is he gonna fart or is he going to
shart or cough here we go
[Laughter]
can we sound like that i have it go for
it
i mean
that's tough because it seems like a
cough but there's a lot of gurgling yeah
i'll slow down i feel like he was
clearing his throat too hard and then he
[ __ ] his pants you think it's both yeah
i'll slow it down go
ahead whoa
it's like the family guy meme where he
coughs and then like
tries to hide him farting with a cough
yeah exactly
i think i i i think it's a cough
i think it's got to be a cough that's a
number
play the replay the regular one
that's a lot though
[Music]
that's just like a whole symphony i just
want to point out all the lemon juice he
has probably to make his garlic and
fragile mix garlic
is just full of bottles of lemon juice
man that's a little marley look there's
no doubt i'm very [ __ ] his pants before
but
i think this is a cough i think he's
clearing his throat i think so too i'm
just concerned by how much fluid appears
to be in his lungs
that's that's not a normal cost
that's just like a whole it's like
there's like a whole story arc in that
cough yeah absolutely i'll pitch it up
people are saying it's not a cough
should we get should we put it to a vote
here oh we could yeah i just for sure
i have a poll running now asking our
audience if they are uh partaking in the
festivities today and 41 say they are so
that's a lot of people a lot of people
shout out to my
to my peeps out there who are blazed
all right but i'll end that and we want
to do a poll on this wally video coffer
chart
[Music]
just don't see it being a shark oh
someone said this is does he a hookah
smoker do you guys have that intel not
that i've ever seen in any other videos
congratulations
you've
what on earth was that what's that
dan was watching this at work and i
didn't know what it was i just heard it
and i thought someone was ripping ass in
the mosque
i'm sure that happens i mean you can't
hold it yeah people are saying cough
cough but it
pretty divided
and i think it's a calm but the man i
hope he sees a doctor because that that
ain't
hates doctors that's like a straight up
pneumonia cough
that's a lot of phlegm that's not good
more fun than gary dell about her
right
i saw this what is wrong with people the
easter egg wait oh no did you see the
easter egg video of the that couple
stomping on the eggs
oh no i thought that's what this was no
i think you'll enjoy this though
okay we got a helicopter
flying really low
hovering
he's dropping eggs yep what the hell
it's like an air strike
there's like a whole family
wait what yeah uh wait give me the audio
i'll mute it for just a moment
[Music]
no [ __ ]
people are running for their lives
i mean he's like a good like 200 feet up
he's pretty
he's low for a helicopter but still high
for dropping eggs on people
holy [ __ ] dude
oh my god wait someone said post without
the music that's what i want to see if
they did that
oh here here it is without the music oh
beautiful
straight-up airstrike
[Applause]
they're running oh my god there's like
babies in the clouds
the uh
the original post somebody asked if
anybody got hurt and they said no it was
fine i mean they're hard-boiled eggs
it's just funny what i was assuming they
were the plastic like easter egg hunt
eggs
you think they were dropping actual eggs
i thought that's what people did i don't
know anything about easter i'm not sure
uh no it's just probably candy it's
can't they're plastic a little okay yeah
they're they're relatively lightweight i
mean still dropped from that height
though because the chocolate is more
deadly
i thought hard boiled eggs at first too
i'm not gonna lie yeah yeah i mean
there's nobody easter that would
actually that would probably [ __ ] people
up
it just bounced right off it's like a
little rugby look at that pandemonium
ensues
and that can't be legal to drop [ __ ] out
of a helicopter on people
that ain't up to code i don't think
that's good someone made me in skyrim
or no this is me in skyrim yeah it's
like an amazing edit
let's see
all right well here's what i got planned
next
uh let's go test ride the gatsby
versus the love robot we've built a
little bit of an obstacle course out
there
these guys are so worried i don't know
you guys are so worried i'm gonna hurt
myself it's not that crazy
i'm really worried
you're really worried yeah you all are
really worried
yeah
it weighs like two thousand why though
it goes like 25 miles
wow it's been a minute since i played
this game great game though
what the hell
it's my office i own this place
that's all
that's very
good
i wonder why they decided to put us in
scott it's just such a random idea but i
love it i think they were practicing
their uh rotoscoping skills and uh more
please yeah please shout out to the
creator
was um who are you
you would be
cal grump cal grump shout out to the
creator more please
demand it
shout out to jaden smith i know we've
been talking about the wolf man uh
family
you know jayden is obviously really well
adjusted intelligent kid
how old is he before i start goofing on
him
he seems really young still i thought he
was 23. oh he's 23. man [ __ ] this kid
i hear that crazy stuff and then i would
just a meeting about their next film or
something and they would put me at the
head of the table
and just
make me sit there while they're talking
debate with all these people talk we'll
talk numbers talk crazy stuff and then i
would just from a young age always being
around that always seeing that like i am
very happy that i spent my childhood
with more adults than i did with kids
because i was picking up more things
from adults than i were from kids my own
age and i look and i go around sometimes
and i hang out with other people that
are my age and they're just kind of just
[Applause]
i'm just like dude like oh my god like
can we talk about like the political and
economic state of the world right now
bro i'm literally collapsing in on
myself
it's so embarrassing and this is the are
our eyes reel if mirrors exist kid what
was his original quote i mean he's been
doing this forever and it's like man i
thought
he [ __ ]
i'm going to okay
oh god it's just so embarrassing dude
i'm glad
the quote was how can mirrors be real if
our eyes aren't real
yeah that's it oh i get it yeah
so he's had a lot of great quotes like
that and now of course jaden smith is
getting the meme treatment
there's been lots of good
stuff um
this was a post of him at coachella over
the weekend last weekend
and all the comments are about his
comment
like all the replies yeah did you talk
about the political and economic state
of our country at coachella
let's talk about the political state of
the world
wait oh this is just this one i saw lots
of videos on tick tock of people being
like bro you're a [ __ ] kid like bro
we're just trying we're at recess well
right because i believe he was
i don't know if he said it in that clip
but it i think he was referring to when
he was like 12 or 13. they're like dude
like recess being kids
i hate how this interviewer is just like
enabling them
i don't know i'm working about my own
age and i look and i i go around
sometimes and i hang out with other
people that are my age and they're just
kind of just
i hate that interviewer how he does that
so that's that's big boy he's like a uh
legend in uh
la uh radio hip-hop
yeah he's like a legend so i'm interest
i'm just curious why he had jaden smith
he's famous he's famous and he had an
album yeah within the last year right in
his defense i didn't think
he probably didn't know that it was
going to go there and they assumed janet
smith was going to say
what he did
he's like nope take it back listen
nothing against big boy i just thought
like damn
selfie i'm just like dude like oh my god
like can we talk about like the
political and economic state of the
world right now you're 12. you have that
as a sound bite great that's a great
sound bite yeah oh my goodness
nice we got the whole smith family on
rap apparently the red table talk came
back and they didn't mention any of the
controversies really they pretended like
it didn't even happen that might be the
best move from their perspective i guess
not i'm going to okay
that's this stays funny we talk about
what's going on with the environment can
we talk about other things don't worry i
like to turn like what you don't want to
talk about [ __ ] uh
kickball at recess
i like to play so i like to play songs
loud and jump in the crowd in atlanta
but you know i'm always looking for that
next thing i'm not satisfied at just
like a a party did you ever have a
feeling where you thought
you or
willow y'all y'all had to be perfect
no okay
because i tell my kids hey y'all got to
be perfect yeah yeah
no no no when i'm
ready
well yeah i thought he got out of that
the whole
my eyes aren't real mere stage but i
guess not james smith that we're telling
every kid in recess that they only have
20 years to live because of global
warming
[Music]
that's [ __ ] great
yeah that's like the best walk up to an
award acceptance ever yeah
yeah
actually i really really talk about like
the political economics
ronaldo yeah apparently their newborn
past
really yeah terrific i didn't hear that
yeah
made me sad that's horrible
i mean obviously people go through that
all the time but it's just horrible i
can't imagine
yeah there you go
the man has it all but still
he is a human
still great video
someone said uh cabire said of course
you like being around adults last time
you brought a friend your age over your
mom [ __ ] them
uh
who's joe brandon
joe brandon the president of the united
states joe what's that
persona
let's see joe america is a nation that
can be defined in a single word
i was going to put him
[Laughter]
and that's it just a little goof it
doesn't put him in uh that's that's the
hell of a word there did you find in a
single word
i was gonna put
him and now if you could write that
grammatically that word what would that
be america is a nation that can be
defined in a single word
i was going to put him a
foot
a number
yeah there's some foot foot in there
that that that that that
listen the english language has a lot of
words it's a it's a colorful language
and
maybe if we just not heard that word
before that's true i was going to put
him
oh no i did
these people should be thrown in jail
i'm sorry
you guys probably saw this it was a oh
yeah 37 million views on twitter alone i
saw it on tick tock so
worshiping jesus at 30 000 feet in the
air boy
[Music]
look look at the faces my goodness look
at this man
he's pre he says yeah i do a prayer
right now for this [ __ ] to stop i just
prayed for this plane to crash right
i can't yeah look at this man he is not
feeling it
you know i mean
[Music]
is this like a whole youth group is on
the plane and like a few other poor
souls yeah right yeah because these
people are way too into it
[Music]
can you just like love jesus privately
insecure a little bit it's like you know
what i mean i'm you know i'm sure they
had pure intentions but i think the best
response i saw was just can you imagine
that a muslim was on there and started
doing a muslim prayer oh that was uh
uh what's her name representative omar i
think yeah and then there was like so
many
uh people were like posting such
horrible things in response
but yeah if people started doing uh
islamic prayer that would have been bad
they'd get like headlocks and choked up
they would they would [ __ ] in front like
everyone be like let's roll
everyone's calling their family yeah
honey
it's just
it's so rude honestly it's just straight
up rude to do that it's like i mean i i
personally i like sleeping on planes i'm
able to sleep and it passes the time
quickly i get kind of stressed out on
there and so i just sleep through it and
if all of a sudden half the plane stood
up and was just loudly singing my face
and strumming a guitar wake up in a
panic
leave me alone just leave me alone you
know maybe sign up for this
maybe uh kenneth
copeland was onto something when he said
oh the demons in the tube
[Music]
these people are so [ __ ] annoying
dude
this is a good point who wants to go to
heaven and be with these [ __ ]
do you know like i'm sorry but if this
is the type of people i can expect to
see in heaven count me the [ __ ] out yeah
i'm not trying to listen to this music
hell no yeah
stop it right now
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm sorry but
it'd be like my
to the ground
do you know songs in arabic can you sing
one for us
i i only know a few songs there's one
song that's kind of like a meme i
actually made a video talking about my
walkout song for the fight and it's uh
that was one of the songs i was
considering i don't know how to say in
arabic but it's we just call it nancy i
love you me and my cousins and it starts
off really weird it just is like all
quiet and it goes
nancy
i love you
nancy i love you and there's like a
silence and it's like eh and the song
starts anyways my cousins always say
that that's where dre got the smoke weed
every day like the paws and then the
smoke weed every day from nancy because
there's like a pause on the air
hmm that means i know i don't know yeah
let's see some responses here
because they're always good
but this time not uh there's the
responses don't even make sense what the
hell
why do usually there's like good
responses at the top there's these have
like two likes
interesting
elon this twitter has gone to [ __ ] since
elon oh you have to show more replies
that's right
i spent just a week volunteering at the
train station in poland right across
ukraine border and saw the same people
there
they're playing to ukrainian refugees
stuck waiting hours
[ __ ] bring food not music
[Music]
it is the same people i said maybe
wait what do you think about this
i don't even think they want to hear
this i mean
it's a it is a different scenario than
being trapped in a in a plane with
people but they're they're waiting on a
train station they can't leave never
mind either i don't know how it is in
ukraine but at least here it's not
uncommon to see buskers in the train
station playing music like it's a part
of the
it's part of the vibe it says they were
playing to ukrainian refugees stuck
waiting hours for transportation who
just fled from the bombings
of uh carcave and maripole
mariupol
well you know they're
they're trying to do it what if these
people have been through enough right
god damn
gonna be the one that saves me
[Music]
christ's sake man give it a rest
ukraine is also a little bit more
religious
to uh countries i think but you know
but this is a whole different field of
religious
well i imagine ukraine they're eastern
orthodox which there are not many of
them
denomination i mean they're trying to go
there to help you know i think their
hearts are probably in the right place i
i know i know it's annoying
i mean they're going to a war zone
so well they're in poland
you want to impress me go to the front
lines and sing your [ __ ] okay yeah
how about that you're right i mean
yeah you know what i'm saying
you're my
you guys want to impress me go put on
some bulletproof vests and sing to the
russian troops
let's see how that goes
maybe you can change their hearts
yeah there you go that's true
so so charm them with your music
it's like the pepsi pepsi vibes yeah
yeah exactly yeah yeah thank you
i'm not impressed at the poland's train
station
you know
oh god i
just thought you had kennedy these
people could be considered international
terrorists frankly
could be dependent on them they're on
planes they're in poland
what a break
what are you gonna do without muppets
ooh
a kermit the frog jordan peterson parody
i just saw it come across the uh
subreddit the other day what the hell
are we gonna do without men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the sewers
they're up on the power lines in the
storms and the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works in a miraculous
manner
they work themselves
to death
and now often literally
and
the the
um
solidly laboring working-class men
breaking themselves
on a regular basis
[Music]
and
it's
very
useful to tell
just men that they have
an important role to play
a necessary role and that if they
act properly and honestly that
they can put their lives together and
they can help their families oh that's a
[ __ ] torture
let's not identify that we got in
trouble for that last time
what keeps the world going slanky eh
what the hell are we gonna do without
men
they're working in this rain and wind
shout out to the creator nimr nimrod
shout out nimrod nimrod zagluri
animation
you know pretty good
that's an israeli name
is it
but it's probably
used by others say
the israelis
what are we going to do without men
their work what are we going to do with
old men they're working around the city
that's the video they're working in the
dirt
and the sun
and the rain and the sleet
the volcanoes
they're working while they're high
it's true and they're blasted out of
their mind that's true i'm so tired of
people comparing me to that [ __ ] frog
oh boy
[ __ ] that frog he doesn't know anything
about my struggles the only meat he's
eating is a piggy i'm getting a little
bit of yoda vibes
strong with the first young one learning
you are the same voice actor well later
on yo shout out frank oz yeah really
well once jim henson died frank oz took
over for kermit i believe
they're meaning
no he's been no that's true i don't know
anything about their voices no frank oz
he was he was like jim henson's best
friend and yeah he did the voice of yoda
and the puppetry for it in star wars and
when jim henson died he took over his
kermit
uh there is a guy named frank oz who did
the puppet of yoda we have such a meme
about friends
i don't know when they're being can't
believe that they introduce everything
to frank yeah so that's why
frank frank ozzy osbourne uh the tv show
called oz was written by frank oz
uh the poem ozzy mandy wait hold on
kermit the frog oh this is actually wait
wait wait wait
wait i think they're right yeah this
time
right yeah
every day like if they're like oh who
sings that song exactly oh frank oz yeah
okay he's the ghost
this time he did it all shout out to
frank
out yeah whatever the legend
we'll just find the most ridiculous [ __ ]
that like has the name oz or frank in it
and we'll just be like oh frank i'll do
that
so like oh these guys hold on these guys
are really making the rounds they're
they're with putin singing like come on
he's got it
the man's got a war to fight absolutely
shout out frank oz dude
shout out absolutely putin doesn't look
entertained though you might want to
wrap it up
dip out
all right well thank you guys for
watching this very special 420 blaze it
um
thank you to our wonderful members as
you guys know
uh
we need you now more than ever so thank
you to the people who became members and
i'll
thank you to all of our beautiful
members and thank you to anyone who's
watching obviously not to uh i love all
all of our viewers we love them all
don't we folks
uh leftovers is coming back pretty soon
not next week but the week after is that
right
or it's not next week is it well we're
going to record it next week yes and
then um
[ __ ]
crazy there's been some discussion of
trying to get it as a weekday release
instead of the sunday release like we
used to do that hasn't been solidified
yet
so uh
we'll see but yeah i mean it's coming
back within the next week or so oh there
is some very preliminary talks of a
potential new show in the works
i'm not going to say anything else about
it
but we've got four we're going back to
four episodes a week so those of the
love that the h3 podcast rejoice
and uh again very preliminary but uh got
some other stuff cooking up could be
something exciting cooking up here and
we got some uh the return trisha
just kidding
we're back frenemies is
back
what would frenemies be called if it
came back it would it would just be
called limited be called what limited
lim just limited
why because it only lasts one episode
you know it's crazy if frenemies did
come back people will still watch that
[ __ ]
oh for sure people would watch the [ __ ]
out of that
but
that boat is
not just sailed it sunk
yep it's with the titanic at the bottom
of the ocean
but frankly what i think is coming is
better
yeah and i'm not announcing it so stop
the drone stop with the drum roll very
preliminary very preliminary
well the real frenemies would be me and
oliver
but i would never want to sit next to
that guy yeah or pay him anything
you know
understandable
um anything you guys want to add before
we sign out
uh
i love you
thank you legalize it
joe biden
[ __ ] coward marijuana okay i just
wanted to be clear release all the
non-violent offenders 100
legalize release all drug offense all
drug offenses who aren't that aren't
violent
or like major drug trafficking probably
should be in jail too
by the way teddy fresh looking good the
website teddyfresh.com
spider-shark
uh
follow teddy fresh on tick-tock um
great tick tocks
that's true and we just hit 40 000 on
tick-tock um
the girl who works for basic tick-tock
macy's amazing she is so talented
[Music]
and uh
yeah our tick tock's poppin
this shirt's super nice i love this
shirt
really nice beautiful colors
like the fit too
um
these this whole set was real cool
nice bucket hat underwear
oh the underwear actually sold out
that's interesting
cool
fun tank top i need this shirt i need to
get that shirt
this is
actually what i'm wearing right now
teddy bear sweater
this hoodie is super cool too
and uh hi mom shirt is that ela's
writing
yes it is it's sold out
that one's hype that one always goes
quick it's like
very hype
you know this is the acid wash kind of
base or classic fit classic style
the wash is really cool
i love the classic hoodies it's my
favorite okay cool that's good now we're
actually dropping a class a whole
classics line
i think next month and the colors are
sick
it's awesome it's all like super earthy
washed colors oh i love beige so that's
great yeah
yeah
also really cool necklace trinkets and
all this kind of [ __ ] check it out a
dinosaur
for theodore
a cowboy boot
a gun a duck a phone and a cowboy hat
says it all doesn't it
does it say it all
tells a story tell something it says
something
um
you could be the proud owner of a tiny
uh color block hoodie
i like that
it's just a tiny color black coating
that's dope i haven't seen that that is
so dope yeah it's sick
oh you can store stuff in it too it has
a zipper on the bottom
little
time bag
got a nickel finished lobster claw hook
with the swivel
a lot of detail
is there more pictures of it yes there
is
you know
proud owner look at that it's even got
the uh
i love how they take the close-up of it
like
a real
why won't you let me zoom the [ __ ] out
yeah there it is there it is
work it work it that's a different
product
that would be the
spider t love that
anyway teddyfresh.com you know what it
is you know what to do
so thank you to everyone who supports us
in all these different ways
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
anything you guys want to add i asked
before but zack said he loves me i
didn't forget and anyone else wanted i
got somewhere to be in about eight
minutes so maybe we could just
do you really yeah
you know appointment
are you serious yeah about 4 20. it's 4
28 minutes
i was like dan it's a show dave
you're making appointments on a
wednesday afternoon
you didn't tell me
you're a funny guy
work with me
bingo
that's true
okay i don't make sweden uh
reading sweden illegal too
you can't even [ __ ] do that [ __ ] here
apparently so no sweden dog
oh sweet come on bro
that's so true
well in truth free free all
smoke all free all free everyone just
for every prisons honestly for them all
i think we should empty the prisons
and anyone else who is too violent or
just too dysfunctional should be in like
a mental institution where they like get
treated humanely
i mean that could just
like the we were looking at the the
swedish prisons those look pretty nice i
mean we could
at least start there
because i don't think i don't think
we're polishing prisons in america
anytime soon but we could at least make
it so it's not like a [ __ ]
literal gulag
well people literally
slavery is very profitable it's
literally slave labor
not and also the prisons get paid
ungodly amounts from the
government like 30 000 a year for each
prisoner it's disgusting that's way low
it's way more than that is it really
yeah it's like 70 000 on average people
don't there's like that's like a really
high salary yep people don't even get
paid that much money
uh california
65 per each person incarcerated
and there's and again we have the most
prisoners in the world
um
we are [ __ ] our country is spiraling
uh capitalism this is like capitalism
we're spiraling towards the end of of uh
free democracy because
basically [ __ ] is getting so bad and
propaganda is getting so good that
people can't even identify why their
lives are bad and they're just turning
to uh
they're turning to nationalism
and um fascism
and uh society is going to collapse
if there isn't major changes like
abolishing prison
some kind of universal basic income
making education free
making health care affordable
um
or we will and and the one thing i don't
understand is how these
these uh american oligarchs
don't understand that they are digging
their own graves uh in sweden we spent a
hundred thousand plus per prisoner in
love said that's interesting what's the
what's the population of swedish people
in prison because in america it's like
literally a whole percentage of people
yeah the per capita is probably nothing
compared to the rate here i mean even
even though they're spending more per
prisoner i'm sure the the total is
significantly less seven thousand
seven thousand people in prison in the
country of sweden yeah that seems
exceptional what
7 000 people there's you can literally
count the 7 000
i don't even think we know the amount of
people in prison wait no yeah yeah
that's correct
there's only 7 000 people in prison in
all of sweden that's not necessarily a
good thing because crime in sweden is
very very high we got the highest crime
in europe i think like
yep so all right let's lock them up like
sweden is not the like best
country to compare
there's their prisoners are treated very
humanely though which is good yes
in many ways it's a it's a very good
place
but correct the problem the thing is
with 1000 is that that's not
i'm seeing
so how many prisoners are in america
like i think like oh three and a half
million probably
three and a half million that's like
almost the size of los angeles all uh in
[ __ ] prison
2.3 million
oh
so it's less than a percent wait or it's
a percent of adults i think
[Music]
yeah i just don't understand how all
these american oligarchs don't
understand that if society
becomes
unstable they're gonna they're they're
going to
die
you know what i mean
this says one out of five prisoners in
the world is incarcerated in the us
versus every other country there you go
fifth of them
there you go
someone says racism at the root of the
prison system i agree
i mean if you track it back far
enough basically after slavery was
abolished
they started arresting black people and
if you read the constitution it says
slavery is outlawed except if you're
charged for a crime and a lot of people
got sent back to prison or backed into
slavery for for the crime of whatever
the [ __ ] they wanted it to be
and to this day
um
prisoners
work full days of labor for like a
dollar or even less i don't know
what is this
uh
crime rates
safety
index what does that even mean
he's just saying that the crime rate in
sweden is the highest of any european
country according to
whatever a crime index is i don't know
how that's measured but
yeah we have some horrible politicians
what kind of crime just like petty crime
thefts like kind of thing
our word is like the highest in sweden
oh wow
yeah we got some major issues uh i do
get a little bit annoyed when people say
that sweden is like this utopia because
it's definitely not yeah no places in
many senses sure i agree
uh but yeah we are lacking in some areas
obviously
send some of the american police over
there we'll just kill some people real
fast get them in line yeah we had like a
massive riot uh and uh
not one bullet was shot or like just one
or two bullets was shot
that was apparently very good
love was telling me crazy story about
how someone was a victim of a home
invasion and he just protected himself
and he used a firearm and he ended up
getting in trouble the homeowner did for
using the photo yeah yeah after being
stabbed afterwards he watched his
hunting rifle
and he got he got stabbed and shot a guy
and he got in trouble
yes sir what happened to him
this the dude that got stabbed got
manslaughter i think and uh no other
dude died yeah
no
yes sir
it's wild
well luckily in america i could just
shoot someone for looking at me wrong
from the street
that's basically what george zimmerman
did
oh in america we could drive down
we can drive him down boy
and shoot him like a hog
anyone here from arizona
arizona hell yeah baby
those gators in arizona i tell you what
those dogs i can't stop saying gators
anyone here for marriage yeah
dana and i were like wrapping some
cables yesterday and i was just like
going through my head of all these like
like efu area anyone here from arizona
also it is officially 420 on the west
coast
as of this month blaze blaze blaze
go for it all of our west coasters
congratulate college even in santa cruz
everyone will go on 420 out to the giant
field and years would come where the
police would come and break it up
now it's lego man
yeah there's still because we looked
into um
when we were thinking about what we
would do for today consider doing it on
the field thing and looked for large
events and the thing is even though it's
legal it still needs to be a permitted
event in los angeles county if it's uh
going to be like a public thing like
that and they're refusing to issue any
so there aren't any like big gatherings
in l.a
it looks like official ones you know
mindfulness yeah
we show i'm sure down in there and stuff
[Music]
the green is my religion every day i
grow it in the ground and it grows
strong from the sun and earth
blaze
space
blaze
wrap it up black my dick and uh hey
please
please you're crushing your man so good
so good
man we tell them don't stay
i can't really hear the the beat
so i'm kind of improvising crank it
hey here we go
i
we wrap it up in the morning man embrace
and in the evening we hit another one
and when the man come to me and say
that joint out i say hey no way
[Music]
let's take us out on this
[Music]
[Music]
you